foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Venue at the hotel Natura in the city of
Reykjavik Iceland here at the 2022
Fisher random world championship this is
going to be another exciting day I'm
Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski it is a
pleasure to be bringing you the
commentary once again with International
Master Lawrence Trent the legend
Lawrence good afternoon I suppose well
we have a new prime minister every time
I commentate with you and hopefully
we're gonna have some interesting chess
today how are you feeling how excited
are you for another day official random
action
I'm excited for another day official
random action I'm not particularly
excited for the future of British
politics and other another robot another
piece of the the system in government uh
we won't go there though shall we
um as for the Fisher random commentated
yesterday blinding chess uh some I'll be
honest with you Daniel I said this
throughout the stream yesterday don't
understand any of it I'm I'm watching
some of these positions I've got
absolutely no idea what's going on
hopefully you'll be able to help me out
a little bit more
um but there were some wild stuff
yesterday
there was some wild stuff indeed and I'm
pretty pessimistic on the being able to
help you friend I'm about as clueless as
you are but let's make sure that nobody
is clueless when it comes to Fisher
random what it is and what the rules are
Fisher random also known as chess 960 uh
is a version of Chess where the pieces
start in one of 960 random starting
positions of course it is different from
normal chests and other pieces have a
different starting configuration the
black and white pieces start in the same
setup so the pieces are still
symmetrically reflected and otherwise
all standard chess rules apply if it
talks like a knight and walks like a
knight and looks like a knight it still
moves like at night all the pieces move
the same way and castling works in the
same way as well perhaps Wesley so he
could do well to review this uh to
review this graphic Lawrence
I mean we were shocked yesterday because
I I'm still not completely clear on what
happened because it feels so strange to
me that Wesley mistook the fact that
even in 960 that when you're checked you
can still Castle I mean it doesn't make
sense to me I I I still can't get my
head around it to be brutally honest but
uh there you go
um even the best players uh can
get the rules wrong in nine in nine six
or a fish around them it's so new to
everybody still relatively speaking
it is indeed but that makes it a little
bit more exciting and speaking of
exciting I'm a big fan of the format in
uh these Fisher random World
Championships it's Unique uh it's
interesting it caters to some exciting
chess the players are divided into two
groups they play a double round robin so
everybody plays everybody in two
separate two game matches uh each match
consists of two games and if you win the
match doesn't matter if you win with a
score of one and a half or if you wipe
off your opponent with a 2-0 victory you
get assigned two points for a match win
one point for a match draw with a score
of 1-1 and zero points for a loss in the
top two of each group Advance Into The
Knockout that means there will be four
players two from each group that Advance
into the final knockout the time control
rapid 25 plus zero and after 30 moves to
avoid crazy flagging Lawrence I telling
you for the record I didn't vote for
this uh but the players are given five
extra minutes and a third and a five
second increment comes into effect your
take on sort of the the format and the
time control
yeah so
I mean I was discussing this at the at
the top of the show yesterday uh the
format I like the groups how they're
divided up and going into the knockout
that's will find the time control is
honestly the strangest time control I've
ever witnessed we're talking about after
move 30 or 31 you get extra time never
seen it before maybe it's good maybe
it's a great idea I don't particularly
know
um more tests will be required for sure
but
um certainly it it it it it certainly
generates interest from you know a uh
getting into time travel we saw
yesterday Matthias bluebound on numerous
occasions get very close to flagging
before move 30 against Magnus so it
leaves quite a bit of intrigue in that
sense
um but yeah
um certainly in terms of the general
format and the two groups the way
everybody plays each other I'm totally
for
30 30 moves is a lot for official random
game so time scrambles definitely come
into effect let's review the group
standings going into today in group a we
have the reigning world rapid Champion
the Uzbek Phenom he has been I mean
taking the Chess World by storm
everything he touches on the chessboard
kind of turns into gold these days and
this tournament has been no exception no
Rebecca De sotorov has eight points a
three-point lead over Yan apontry as he
clinches uh a qualification spot
technically Jan could still come in
first but remember the top two players
from each group get into The Knockouts
and Notre back can breathe easy he is
just I mean at 18 years old the mark
that he's already left on the Chess
World is immense and you just get this
feeling Lawrence he's like a rookie
LeBron James the fact that his Jessica
is just getting started is pretty
terrifying and so is his record in this
tournament thus far
well what can we say about this young
man he's been Sensational uh no no
hyperbole there
leading Uzbekistan obviously to winning
the Olympiad World rapid Champion uh
doing fantastically against these top
players and
winning with ease so far this uh this
partic this particular group he's looked
Unstoppable even when he's been losing
you didn't really get the feeling like
he was going to lose for example against
Greta sin yesterday was Stone lost but
he's got this confidence he's got the
resourcefulness
uh he's got the talent
and uh he's running away with the group
and fully expect him to to win that
group
and then of course he'll be playing very
stunned competition in the next round
he will indeed and he will be facing Jan
and Wesley today so we'll be keeping a
close eye on his games and in the other
group we have a more tightly contested
race Carlson and Nakamura not a big
surprise there uh currently sharing
first with six points but Vladimir
fedexev he is a terrifying opponent in
all formats and he is still very much in
the running with four points he needs a
strong performance today and
unfortunately Matthias bluebaum just not
his tournament we could see the
disappointment on his face as he lost a
couple of painful games throughout the
days but still this is an experience of
a lifetime for him but Lawrence when
you're facing Magnus Carlson you're
facing the world champion
arguably the greatest Blitz player who's
ever lived I mean that is just a tough
group and Vladimir fed to say of course
nobody to sneeze that either this is a
brutal group and uh any group that
features Magnus Carlson just by
definition uh it's going to offer a
difficult Journey to the top as we take
a look at the smile and face of the
world champion
yeah absolutely I mean Magnus you know
uh one of the reasons why
you know he's
um I'm gonna gonna make the big and very
valid claim to be the greatest of all
time is just because he he is able to
win in all chess formats we we think
about previous world champions uh they
didn't manage to do it now maybe they
didn't have the opportunity to do it
true maybe the these taught you know for
example the Fisher random World
Championship perhaps didn't exist in the
times of Kasparov and so on nevertheless
that's not magnus's fault so for Magnus
to be able to excel win this it's a very
important tournament for Magnus I know
Magnus very well as a lot of people know
he really considers this a very special
tournament and he's gunning to win it
um yesterday Matthias bluebound what a
chance he missed he was so infuriated by
not being able to
uh well by actually by losing I mean he
should have at least not lost let's say
against Magnus uh but he was pressing
the whole game with why it didn't manage
to do it
very very frustrating Dave for Matthias
who's out of the tournament it will be
invaluable experience for him however
but we're gonna see a big uh let's say
um uh Battle of these top guys uh for
sure today I'm very curious will emerge
from that group better say a very tricky
customer another player who I simply
don't understand I don't understand any
of his moves
um very creative guy uh very capable
um yeah so we'll confirm that that he
sometimes doesn't understand himself as
always you know you're in for a trip
whether he wins or loses it's going to
be an exciting game uh and we are going
to have so many exciting matches today
so buckle your seat belts settle in and
uh before the games begin a quick review
of today's matches uh here at the world
Fisher random championships presented by
Brave the game's about to kick off and
you can see here so against gretcherson
that can wear a blue bomb better say if
Carlson looking forward to that one and
yawn the palmistry against Abdul satorav
and Lawrence let me tell you Jana Palmer
Street he's taking it personally he does
not like to lose 2-0 I mean Jan of all
people he is just going to be putting
every ounce of energy as we see him
adjusting his seating position there a
smile on his face he seems relaxed
enough but he's gonna let try to let his
moves do the talking
absolutely
um
you know there's no question yeah no
publishing one of the greatest talents
the game has ever seen in fact this
Clash here is is really The Clash for me
of the realm I mean to see both of these
guys Uber talents natural talents uh
fight it out is is a real treat and uh
I've got no real opinion on who who I
like either that's the funny thing I
don't have a real opinion on on who I
really like in this in this either
um it feels like a total coin flip to me
so 100 let's see what happens yeah
well we could see the handshake and the
grub S8 by Vladimir fedesev one thing
not to forget this is Fisher random the
pieces are arranged differently and the
position is revealed a couple of minutes
before the round begins so we will try
to give you a sense of what's going on
in the starting position as we try to
figure it out ourselves in real time so
Lawrence looking at this position of the
queen tucked away in the corner the
Kings on C1 and C8 and FedEx coupons
already on the fourth rank what are your
instinctual thoughts here
difficult one isn't it
um yeah you can see I mean you you need
time to adjust don't you even you know
I'm looking at this position and it
seems as though you're getting the queen
active makes a lot of sense because
Queen on H1 of course pointing towards
the center uh makes it makes a whole
bunch of sense
um yeah the Bishops look like they're
gonna play an interesting role today
actually to be honest uh gonna be
interested to see how how those guys are
developed uh throughout today uh very
very interesting indeed and yeah uh the
king as well is positioned in a similar
way to yesterday whereby
you know uh castleing uh is
uh is going to be interesting when you
Castle long it's going to be a very long
castles to the king side
working on C1 uh which is always fun to
see it's aesthetically very pleasing to
actually see that on the board as well
um so that will be uh that will be fun
um and yeah uh let's see what happens
I'm curious if there's a consensus as to
the opening move I remember yesterday in
the last round for example when I was
discussing before the game with our
tours you know what is the correct you
know the opening move and we both went
for C4 we both thought C4 was the right
move in that position from yesterday and
lo and behold the Masters did play that
so very very curious to see uh how this
all develops well they were waiting for
Lawrence Jones recommendation and then
you know before deciding on the first
move but that is I don't remember who
made this point uh it was an ishigiri I
think somebody somebody of that uh
caliber but the fact that you often have
mistakes really on
sometimes on the very first move is part
of what makes Fisher random so excited I
mean so exciting you could have some
players with familiarity uh in the
starting position it is possible to
study a lot of the starting positions
even though there's 960 of them but more
often than not you have the players
thinking on their feet from move one
move to move three and you could have
serious howlers committed uh with really
either color in uh you know on the very
first move so here we have Carlson
taking a sort of more traditional
approach he's playing in the center uh
he's putting together kind of a French
type of setup with pawns on E6 and D5 I
am more inclined to to trust his setup
more fedexv is playing a lot on the
flank here uh but one problem that
Vladimir could experience uh has to do
with central control like if Carlson
brings his Pawn up to C5 uh he's gonna
be controlling a lot of these squares in
the center making it difficult for
Vladimir uh to really maximize the
activity of his minor pieces I really
like the move C5 here for Magnus
yeah uh me too uh I think uh you know
fair to save I mean yesterday I I again
if you told me this was going to be a
setup
I just I I I I struggle very much to to
guess very much but looks as though yeah
Magnus goes for 97 however
which of course is is plausible
um
yeah I I I I I I I I don't I mean I
don't have a strong opinion either way
of this setup actually for either color
it feels pretty standard it feels as
though some of the other games have gone
a bit wild I mean I'm looking at the
Nakamura game absolutely yeah let's
let's switch to the Nakamura again
because this this game is still sort of
taking on a relatively normal character
we need to wake up wait a couple of
moves to see if White's flank strategy
uh is going to result in success so
we'll take a rain check on this position
and in the Nakamura game yeah I agree we
have something quite a bit Wilder Hikaru
has the white pieces now in contrast of
Vladimir he starts with a central
approach E2 E4 blue Baum uh one of the
noted French top French experts in the
world true to his form he won E6 D4 D5
so we have a French Advanced no G3
that's not a move you see every day and
unmove three of a French
so Hikaru opens up his Queen and
bluebound does the same and this
Lawrence is a very interesting debate
that players often have do you play G3
to open up the queen or do you push the
pawn two squares and the motivation
behind that is that you grab more space
while you're at it but obviously when
you push upon two squares you're also
introducing more weaknesses in your
position and I think that's what Hikaru
tries to exploit right off the bat by
taking on D5 if bluebonn would have
recaptured to the pawn he would have had
to reckon with potentially a very nasty
check on H3 and so blue bomb already
burning into his clock
and experiencing some indecision about
what to recapture with and he does take
back with a pawn
and there we go yeah yeah and take are
already saying I've got a big positional
edge here the F5 Square extremely weak
the pawn on G5 is potentially a Target I
like G3 just to go back to your prior
Point Dania uh I do like G3 compared to
G4 in that particular position I like
being a bit more humble uh in the
approach and you know Paul mates he kind
of he struggled in the first two games
of State got something going but I feel
like Hikaru is uh absolutely the wrong
opponent for him stylistically uh I feel
like he's gonna really have difficulties
today with both colors against Hikaru I
expect uh I actually expect a pretty
pretty big whitewash actually from
Hikaru today in this particular matchup
I don't like Black's position already
and it looks as though the bar kind of
agrees as well
yeah I mean I just don't like the fact
that Black's already experiencing all
these weaknesses you pointed it out at
five square on on G5 so white has an
easy target for his dark squared Bishop
uh but I think we're gonna see uh likely
see Hikaru copying blue bombs develop on
our approach and the Knight on A1 just
doesn't have that many options I think
it's safe to say it's going to jump into
B3 and now let me clarify one thing in
order for white to Castle queenside uh
The Rook from D1 is gonna have to move
out of the way correct and then the Rook
from B1 is going to slide over correct
that's the way I have interpreted
believe it or not we were trying to make
uh some castles it answers was
desperately flicking over the king but
there was I don't know if it was a bug
or something sometimes there are bugs of
course
um you know these things do happen uh
but yes I I believe that is the rule
okay so and an interesting decision here
from Hikaru I guess I stand corrected he
might actually be bringing his night out
to C2 uh playing against the black queen
trying to keep it totally out of the
game because it's biting on a serious
chunk of granite that pawn on D4 is so
well protected so Hikaru may be taking a
somewhat more conservative approach here
Knight C2 and later Lawrence the Knight
could swing out to E3 and really clamp
down on this F5 Square making it
difficult for black uh to fix these
gaping holes on the king side the White
Queen can also jump into F3 at a
moment's notice with the same exact idea
I think it's important for white to try
to control uh these light squares and
put pressure on black C5 Pawn
yes totally agree uh
seems like a very sensible strategy in
this particular position so curious to
see how this one develops
yeah we could also see a move like H4
from Hikaru using this Pawn as kind of
firewood to uh start the flame on the
king side but definitely a solid Edge
for Hikaru but the position has
stabilized shall we take a gander at our
other two matchups especially nepo of
just a tour of I know that's what people
in the chat are itching to look at so
let's absolutely let's have a look here
as we have a beautiful bird's eye view
there you can see all four boards uh on
your screen and the nepo business tour
of game over on the top right so let's
take a deep dive into that one Jana
promise she has the white pieces
and okay so he much like Vladimir
fettise have started the game with one
G4
and I'm just a tariff taking a central
approach as well oh I I do want to I I
do want to just um
this is a little off script but I I do
want to take a moment actually today is
actually a bit of a sad day
uh unfortunately we received some from
some very sad news uh today
International
Master Michael Bassman uh passed away
today uh the legendary the legendary
Mike Bassman who was pretty much the
driving force behind uh junior chess in
the UK and unfortunately today uh he he
did pass away and because of course you
mentioned the move one G4
um Michael Bassman was the the the
Creator effectively of the grob opening
um and playing G5 with black and all of
these wacky openings uh he brought a
smile to a lot of people's faces
um and he was a very pleasant guy I
didn't know him extremely well of course
I saw him a lot when I was a junior
because I participated in a lot of the
events nevertheless it's very very sad
day for English chess commiserations and
and and obviously condolences to uh
everybody close to him and who worked
with him and his family
um so I I you know uh this is G4 is is
for you today Mike and yeah
uh that's very sweet thank you for for
mentioning that I I'm quite familiar
with the name I've uh you know he he
caught my eye years ago when I was just
digging around on chess face and seeing
which title players played you know E4
B5 and sometimes he played E4 A6 but it
was very obvious from the games that he
wasn't doing it out of disrespect for
his opponent he was a strong player no
no and uh you know much like Tony miles
uh defeating Anatoly karpov with 24 A6
he won a lot of noteworthy games in his
offbeat opening so thank you for that
um and in the game we have this current
position nepo has just swung his Queen
from well swing is the wrong word I
guess slid his Queen from H1 up to H2
and again we have an interesting sort of
Battle of competing philosophies where
noderbeck has better control of the
center he's got the pawn on D5 but Jana
is controlling Central squares from a
distance with his pieces right the
Knight the queen are aiming at the five
square so he's sort of initiating a dark
skirt campaign to try to make it as
difficult as possible for black
uh to to move his pieces around in the
center what do you make of Yan's
strategy here I like it a lot I I re and
queen H2 is such a lovely little move
you know just nudging that Queen up to
control some of those dark squares must
have been a very pleasing move to make
and yeah as you know if you've got A3
Bishop B4 of this dark squared bind that
you could get here seems uh seems great
doesn't it so I mean yeah massively
massively loving how yarn is approaching
this game and I've just settle off with
with some problems hit to solve here I
think strategically speaking
yeah Beyond playing this like an artiste
A3 and Bishop A4 let's try that on for
size and I think the big question here
is whether Notre Beck can get away with
an early C5 I would be very reluctant to
play this move because I mean it not
just justifies the placement of White's
Queen it makes White's Queen into a
Three-Headed Beast but maybe it's worth
the price of admit maybe it's it's a
worthy price to pay because allowing
White's Bishop to jump into before
Lawrence gives away a total Monopoly
over a lot of these key Center squares
and queen side squares
yeah I totally agree it looks forced to
me actually it feels like one of those
as you said that you don't particularly
want to play but you might be
you might be forced to play you know
um
because I I just can't allow Bishop B4
Knight bd4
Etc so I just like it doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel like I can allow that
stuff
to be brutally honest
so I agree I agree completely
so I do I do think C5 will be playing
and I think Abdul saturov is the right
guy to sort of play that move as well I
don't think he's going to be too
scared let's say about playing that move
but then what and then and then white
actually has to think about what he
wants to do
but I do like White's position
nonetheless feels feels very solid yeah
no question that happens better also the
Knight on G8 is a very hard time getting
out especially if you play C5 because
you need to maintain contact with that
pawn so you know for the time being the
position is is closed enough there's no
direct confrontation between the armies
but eventually black will require the
services of the Knight on G8 and this uh
configuration of the pawn uh three
squares away is something uh Robert Hess
always likes to point out the pawn
totally restricting Knight's mobility
and I'm just a star if he took his time
but Queen E7 E8 so he actually
prioritizes the development of his
Knight over playing C5 that comes as a
surprise to me but I get it he wants to
get his pieces out but I mean the eval
bar is not exaggerating here I think Yan
is clearly better he's got his type of
position and he needs to try to strike
while the iron is still hot uh somehow
try to make a find a way to convert his
control over the dark squares into
something tangible into some sort of an
attack not totally sure how to do that
that's why I'm sitting in my cabinet and
Jan is over in windy Reykjavik uh
playing the Fisher random World
Championship Knight bd4
that's the answer heading for B5
yeah something similar happened in the
game yesterday actually with feather say
again with the night landed on B5 A7 was
very weak uh and he had a night kind of
dislocated on 87 it was all rather
rather odd but um I do want to say uh
can we go to the Wesley so game we've
got Iris opening my mouth to ask you the
same question
so a quick view of the bird's eye view
here the Wesley so game over on the top
left and you can see that White Knight
on B7 so to the Wesley so game we go as
he faces the the windless cure of our
Stein gretzerson Icelandic number one
who has had a very rough go of it and
Lawrence this game seems to be no
exception that Knight has just captured
a Pawn on B7 white has the bishop pair
and that Knight is safely getting out
either via C5 or via A5
which graduation tries to prevent from
happening with the Mover of D5 but this
looks pretty Grim for black right out of
the gate
looks looks toast doesn't it really to
be honest I mean uh you can even just go
Knight C5 here which is what it does
and I see absolutely no way
to
uh to to survive here as black uh so a
rough start once again for gretasan
who's just not been able to get anything
going this event he's the local boy I'm
not saying that there's a I don't think
there's a ton of pressure on him because
clearly he's the
you know the lowest rated and it isn't
really expected to to perform Miracles
here but I think he will be a bit
disappointed that he didn't he isn't
doing at least a little bit better than
what he's currently doing
um
so yeah this is
this is a disappointing start for him
today and he's in humongous trouble
yeah and I was going to suggest that we
analyze Bishop takes C5 and Rook takes
C5 out on the ground I have to analyze
it because it's going to appear on the
board so Rook takes C5 restores the
material advantage and it also threatens
Checkmate on C2 but having the bishop
pair in this type of position of the
black king as permanently weak as it is
is precisely what defines White's huge
Advantage I'm curious how Wesley is
going to proceed after Rook takes C5 if
we pull up an analysis board Lawrence
any moves that sort of occur to you here
and I guess we could refresh because
Rook C5 is indeed what do you think
Wesley's gonna do yeah it's an
interesting one
um it's a very interesting one
I would say queen D3 uh looks like Queen
B3 is also interesting just just
exchanging Queens that's also very
interesting yeah
is very much a Wesley style move because
yeah after the trade Black's not gonna
get checkmated but Black's Pieces Just
you know to put it scientifically they
suck I mean maybe Knight bd5
but even something like Rook A1 hitting
the pawn on A7 looks mighty mighty
appetizing for white looks looks
horrible two Bishops pulling up
now this is just over basically I don't
well you're not a butt up oh sorry am I
are we not opponent I beg you pause
sorry I miscounted it it did feel it
felt like it but feels like a pool the
fractured pawns uh nevertheless yeah I
don't see
I don't I I don't see any any way that
you you survive this not against a
technician like Wesley either no no
forget about it
I think Queen B3 is you know the moment
he spots this move he's he won't be able
to resist Queen trade restrict the
Knight open the a file and uh yeah
greterson's just not able to to get his
feet under him especially with the black
pieces I mean these guys are just buzz
saws they come right after you with
white from seemingly any position and
you just have to maintain that Baseline
accuracy in the first couple of moves to
avoid this kind of scenario Wesley
taking his time he's got plenty of it
and I think we're gonna see a confident
Victory from him in this first of two
match games against gretcherson
where to from here let's go back to the
bird's eye view for a bit
um the Nakamura game is what the
publishing Nakamura game is starting to
get spicy as is actually all of the the
other games are starting to nicely spice
up here I mean we have over on the top
right you have nepo against the sort of
that looks pretty interesting but we
were just there so
I'm gonna narrow this down to Nakamura
blue bomb or feta save Carlson I'm gonna
give you the choice between these two
games
spaghetti chicken or pasta
yeah international well I tell you what
as I'm preparing for this boxing match
as a lot of people may or may not know
I've been having a lot of chicken and
not so much pasta so let's go for
chicken let's go for
let's go for Nakamura let's quickly go
back there okay
Nakamura it is and we remind you that he
faces German Grandmaster Matthias blue
balm
okay so what do we have here well
Bluebell has expanded on the king side
but it comes at the cost of a very weak
Pawn that has landed on F4 attacking
hikaru's night on E3 bluebound okay
neither side has castled yet Hikaru has
put himself in a position where he can
Castle what castling really means in
this position is bringing the Rook on B1
into the game that's literally all it
does but that's an important thing to do
because
you know the center is sort of open and
you need the services of both of your
Rooks
precisely
um
yeah this is
this is not this is not straightforward
uh
what would you do here Dania
if you what what
um
well I would move the Knight let's let's
start with that I know nobody nobody
realized that's a mind-boggling claim
okay actually I might want to go Rook G1
and then Knight g495.
because I think matthias's idea is to
meet the obvious move Knight C2 with
Knight jumping into C4 and if you take
on C4 then you give up all of the light
squares and you let the black bishops
light up to C6 this is
maybe still good for white but not in
hikaru's style
I think the Rook G1 Knight G4 idea looks
a lot more appetizing because here you
Force black to either be the one to give
up his light squared bishop or uh the
Knight jumps into E5 with pretty
terrifying effect maybe black can still
play Knight C4 but
this I think is very much up your car's
alley yeah
yeah this I like very much this side
this I really like
I can I can definitely see this
happening
um
I think this will happen actually oh
we've got oh no that's another sorry I'm
looking at a bit of the preview here but
it's a completely different game yes I
like this I like this recipe very much
Rook g194 feels classical feels clean
feels like the sword of thing Hikaru may
very well do so I like kikaru's position
I think black is what's the word
overextended I think is the right word a
little overextended yeah
on the king side the square on E5 is is
so much easier more easily accessible to
whitesnites Black's nights are poorly
coordinated
and no Hikaru dropping his knife back to
you too I'm surprised I mean the fact
that he was taking his time indicates to
me that he was aware of Rook chiwan
otherwise he would have played faster
but he wants to go directly for the F4
pawn and I still think that he wants to
put a knight on E5 so what he's saying
is that Knight C4 runs into Bishop takes
F4 and if blue bomb spends a Tempo
defending the pawn then Hikaru can still
put a knight on E5 and that further
justifies the placement the seemingly
awkward placement of this Knight on G2
so he is aiming directly for the F4 Pawn
that is his principal goal here okay I
can I can kind of get behind it I still
like Rook chew on I'm still partial to
that idea but uh Hikari trying to play
more concretely
yes
so yeah uh Luke still looks reasonable
still prefer white but I much preferred
your line what about sorry we have to go
to fair to save because okay I mean oh
my only feather save could get a
position like this
explain to me what I'm looking at okay
well that's uh the bird's eye view
that's the bottom right of your screen
you can see a white Pawn sitting on F7
and that's all we need to know where to
go next Vladimir has the white pieces
here
okay I'm still adjusting my eyes to this
because I'm not sure what else white has
going for him other than this Sitting
Duck on F7 that resembles a soldier that
has decided to wage a war all on its own
that's like Stannis baratheon's Army in
Game of Thrones I mean you're you're
down to like five soldiers and you're
fighting an entire Kingdom Queen to f8
and look at that Beast of a knight on C4
you know what I think feta save is not
gonna do I can't tell you what he is
gonna do
somehow I don't think we're gonna see B3
I don't really know why I'm just getting
a hunch that he's not gonna try B3 of
course it's because of Bishop A3 yeah
Bishop A3 would end proceedings but his
position is is bad I mean this is this
is no this is not good for FedEx I mean
the bar also agrees
you know the night on C4 is causing
immense problems the night
what happened you you got no nothing
you've lost okay
but we'll get something okay but let's
finish processing this game
yeah
okay yeah now as I was saying uh yeah
now Queen G6 rookie I no I mean this
looks this looks even a bit too random
for fitter seven this Knight on A1 is
such a problem piece uh that's kind of
one of the big issues so yeah not not
feeling this at all but I think we've we
probably should go to to the game you've
just gasped at uh
uh Dania because uh well yeah we have a
breaking news alert no this is clearly
in magnus's control I mean the pawn on
E3 is weak as soon as Magnus eliminates
the F7 Pawn on the next move he
basically has a free hand uh in this
position but onwards we go
tune to partnership I'm just a tour of
now I was looking at this without the
engine obviously I was looking at the
small board preview now that I have the
large board in front of me nothing
changes I think he has indeed blundered
a piece it was a click bait
wow
C5 is such a how how do you blunder C5
it's just totally bizarre so he went
here which is fine because okay 97 and
now Bishop B4 walking right into I mean
Rook D5 what the heck Yon
and now Bishop A5 he said oh let me
threaten Checkmate no no that ain't
gonna work because B6 cuts off
the C7 score and attacks the bishop this
is
this is just down a piece I mean just
mix it up but he's completely lost
this is just so bizarre to me uh
huh
I have no idea
I cannot explain this this this and yeah
we'll keep the poker face because he's
quite good at that so he'll play E4
confidently and then he'll be like yeah
it was all in my plans blah blah blah
when we know the truth
uh it was a sacrifice yeah it was the
night I was Knight F5 here I think
simply ends it yeah what John's trying
to do is counter-attack this this bishop
on on F7 and if you drop the bishop back
to G8 and maybe there's some sort of a
check on G4 but Knight F5 is very much a
notre back move if you bring up an
analysis board it looks like there's a
lot going on but in reality everything
Fizzles out and White's just gonna end
up with a bunch of hanging pieces like
if Knight takes F5 then Queen takes E5
and in the event of the queen trade you
have the classic situation Knight is
hanging Bishop is saying look at black
Starks for Bishop controlling the two
key squares that the Knight could jump
onto if instead white takes the bishop
on F7 then it's much the same principle
Queen F7
or no I guess that's not the most
accurate move I was thinking after
Knight F5 brick F5
oh no no here there's Rook d8 oh
you have to be careful
Rook d8 oh wow and B8 is hanging wow so
I guess that the best move here would be
to take on D4 but it's a moot point
because neuterbach has not played Knight
F5 instead
he has directly taken a knight on D4
look at this position I mean just
optically look at these forms oh I get
it this is very beautiful tell me he
wants Knight takes F7 Knight F5 now and
the Knight on F7 is basically trapped
this is good this is good too no but
this is crushing isn't it you don't even
need the extra piece you're just gonna
go D3 and just drive the pawn up White's
Grill
no this is this is absolutely crushing
um wow what a what a what an awful start
for nepo because this position was looks
so nice
I mean I don't know what happened
literally better and yeah we've seen I
mean obviously official random there's
more blunders than Fisher random than
there normally is even in Rapid
tournaments but this is crazy I mean
these are these are we're talking one
more blunder is here you know we're
talking
basic stuff and Jan is I'm sure
castrating himself on the inside he the
last thing he wanted is
um no castigating I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm just yeah I'm sorry I didn't want to
interrupt I thought well he might be
doing that as well but you know
my apologies it was a slip of the tongue
and it's like castigating himself on the
inside that's embarrassing yeah
um
but uh this is good yeah this is
oh yeah this is going to be milked
milked it's add infinitum
uh but no this is this is bad this is
really really really bad
that's uh Buzz Lightyear's favorites to
infinitum and Beyond uh as he
ah yeah this is this is bad weapons yeah
so what if he tries Queen F7 how lost is
this
um
queen of seven
I mean I mean none of this has happened
like the get the game the game is is
you'll see in a minute is is very
advanced
oh okay they've made Moves they should
update moves momentarily but we see that
Bishop is on f8
so I'm trying to figure out
what is happening okay now we've updated
yes
oh my God
so we had CD Knight F7 Knight F5 this we
saw
okay this is what happened bishop f8 and
motorbeck takes the Knight
and then he castles Queen side amazing
so beautiful Gianna's kept the material
balance but that's the only thing going
for white because D3 is just gonna
crunch through White's position
yeah rookie 8 looks very strong here
just kicking the queen away uh you you
can bully black oh sorry bully white in
this position uh if you really want this
looks absolutely disgusting
um
yeah should be winning for black but you
know Yan is a tricky guy and a lot can
happen
so let's see
yeah I mean Jan is one of the trickiest
Defenders
but I think what will make notrebec so
much calmer is the fact that there's
basically nothing at stake here I mean
this is a bonus game he's qualified so
it's such a great feeling hey I'm
beating yawn but even if something bad
happens I'm still going to make the
knockout so but you know this is a
terrifying time to face him I think
there is sort of you know some Merit to
trying to finish first Daniel because
let's assume Magnus does win his group
he doesn't want to face Magnus in the
next round so he has got incentive not
just to lose all of his games right
um yeah if that's you know yeah so so
there is there is something to that
sure
so
no he'll want to win it
um you know he wants to show these guys
as well that he's not just there to to
be a free point in in special situations
yeah A5 I like very much looks like a
great move this this forces the bishop
back and uh
I mean that Knight on F5 is such a
monster but I agree completely I mean he
qualified via the qualifier uh and it
just shows that the difference in
strength is just getting diminished I
mean these young guys they aren't afraid
of anything they play every game to the
maximum
and you know they're just they're just
nightmare pairings as we see uh Jeffrey
Zhang the one and only saying well Dania
ever I think this was the end of my
career Lawrence I think this is so
strong this is the straw that broke the
camel's back I'm getting disinvited from
the cgc finals
an Unstoppable chain of events at the
end which marks the end of my
commentating career there you go
now this this I think marks the end of
Jan's
defensive chances Rook to E5 such a
patient move just cutting off the queen
making space for the black queen
okay let's uh this is an eyesore I think
we should yeah let's let's move on for
sure we should make our Swift departure
from this game let's go back to the
bird's eye view for a bit
uh as we see top left Wesley has not
managed to squeeze all that much out of
his position herbar is up a pawn
and he's eliminated one of White's
Bishops but I think we've got more
important games to get to Lawrence let's
do it on the bottom left we see Carlson
on the bottom right
again same Choice chicken or pasta yeah
um
I like I think we should go and see uh
see uh hikaru's position very quickly it
looks like this this F4 Pawn which we
have been speaking about might actually
be
uh leaving leaving town pretty so pretty
soon
um
yes not not entirely sure
uh what do you do to save it actually
because if you play F3 which is the move
that first comes to mind
then you probably just go 93
and H6 is now also not particularly
um
yeah
not feeling all that safe
I mean also I like that F4 because this
prevents the black knight from jumping
into C4 which it might be blue
Mountain's only active idea because if
you do it here uh then white just wins
with Knight takes D5 that Queen on H2 I
mean Jan positioned his Queen on that
square unfortunately he plundered a
piece Hikaru position to squint on that
square and it's just ideal the queen is
like Napoleon Bonaparte directing
everything from the island it's it's
perfectly positioned and blue bomb with
five minutes on his clock now to make 10
more moves until the increment
it's just I mean it's it's rough to see
it but when you're in bad form these top
guys are like vultures they're gonna
sense it and they're just not going to
let you go I think your car was winning
this in the next 10 15 moves
shout out to Jeffrey Zhong by the way
shout out to Jeffrey uh great guy
um
and he's gifted 10 Subs to chat so well
done to Jeffrey thank you so much for
being so generous
that is incredibly generous yeah I
commentated with Jeffrey yesterday on
the women's candidates we had a great
time and
you know Jeffrey is just Class Act great
commentator so great to see him in the
chat
and you were right uh Lawrence The Pawn
on F4 as Robert would say not long for
this board and Hikaru has eliminated it
nice tactics here Queen G2 Bishop takes
F5 if you take the queen then the Knight
recaptures and simultaneously defends
the bishop and defends the pawn enough
to at the end of the line yeah another
night protecting the pawn is a big deal
as well so this is this is very bad news
uh for
uh for blue bum and I expect him to to
lose this position
wow uh what is going on in the
well I saw a queen land Abdul satorov
has uh truly entered with Queen A2 I
mean he's just swung the guy in which is
which is very nice to see oh my gosh
this is a disaster for Yan he's gonna
lose it I think Jana's just gonna resign
any second now
yeah he's got to give up uh Magnus
Carlson
in control is he not okay that's let's
jump over to that game
at least that's how it looks
uh rookie four on the board this this
looks like a typical typical Magnus uh
situation here uh better better minor
piece Bishop F4 Now sort of being
threatened and all kinds of stuff in the
air this white king does not feel happy
whatsoever in this position
I guess you can
but you can in name all because Bishop
F4 still picks off the exchange
I mean maybe this is the lesson
precisely
maybe this is the Lesser evil otherwise
you could Hey how do you stop Bishop F4
if you play well that's the point
yeah that is that is the point an
essential strategy for Carlson prevails
like he if he wins the game it'll be
because of his control over the e-file
his control over key Central squares
Queen F5 check by Vladimir
so this sends The Black Gang over to B7
where it's really more than happy to go
and I'm curious what fedesaf's follow-up
is going to be what does he do after
King B7
I see no moves
basically
Rook F2
let's pull up an analysis because this
could get spicy Rook F2
worst case scenario you double on the
e-file right and oh and queen F6 I think
there's rookie one check rookie one
check exactly yeah okay exactly takes me
too and Queen no I apologize
but you can go Rook E2 how about that
for a little tactic Daniel and Rook
takes F2 that's one for your books
that's beautiful Rook takes F2
controlling the queen
and winning a piece incredible line
and Carlson's gonna calculate this in
about two milliseconds
yeah
and if you go
yeah yeah if you go King D2 of course
you take the queen first now you can
just take the queen and take the rook
and it's over
it is over indeed yeah and Carlson is
taking his sweet time to play King B7
he's down to four minutes that might be
the only hurdle that stands in the way
of a big victory with the black pieces
here
he has experienced some time pressure
what is giving him so much pause
Lawrence where is he thinking about
going instead is he maybe he's thinking
about Queen D7 or queen E6 he might be
thinking about Queen D7 now Queen D7
drops the pawn on D5 or does it yes I
think it does
yes
you want to go Queen E6
so what happened he did go King B7 Rook
F2
I'm just looking at the live feed
this kind of all did happen he went rock
h8 instead of rookie which also makes a
lot of Simon this is a great move you're
aiming at the H Pawn and you're also
rendering Queen takes F6 utterly uh
untenable because at the end The Rook
infiltrates the second Rank and even
without Queens White's King is busto
I mean how is Vladimir going to hold
this position he's
you know Rome is I guess now right
that's white
you know you always forget in this game
you can actually still do something
crazy like castles long uh which
is your best move I mean what else are
you supposed to do exactly
and something like C4 but that just
seems way too brazen exactly that's the
right sound effect to make when you look
at that move
I don't like C4 I think he's gonna
Castle long
um yeah
I don't see another move motorbike has
one by the way it's official
unbelievable
I mean let's take a moment just to
appreciate how much of a beast he is
yeah he mate maybe got lucky one once or
twice but
players like that manufacture their own
luck
for sure
100 agree
Wesley grandison seems to be holding
against Wesley as well just had a quick
peek there at that position and
that's really good work by choppy who's
as we've already said numerous times had
a lot of problems so far
and Hikaru looks completely winning as
well
yeah Hikaru has won the F4 Pawn he's got
into an end game he's a pawn up and he's
up a bunch of time that's over on the
bottom left you can see White's got that
extra Pawn on F2
and The Rook on F3 in and of itself
presents absolutely no problems
for uh Mr Nakamura but the greterson
game top left equal material like as an
active Knight we don't really have to go
there we don't have to analyze it
specifically but it actually looks like
a pretty Pleasant end game for greterson
maybe he'll be able to score a big
victory especially given what they had
earlier which seemed to be domination
for Wesley
but I think we should watch the rest of
the Hikaru game yeah let's stay let's
stay with Hikaru for sure
and Magnus also in control blue bomb has
11 seconds he might literally not make
it to move 30. yeah blue bomb has been
struggling all the time uh making it
and uh you know uh he might not make it
and his position stinks
and the rookie seven rookie eight
literally anything white is dominating
on all sides of the board look at that
just the bishop on G3 the way that it's
that it's restricting the activity of
black Strokes is really impressive
okay bluebum has made it to move 31 and
he has the additional five minutes
but that that is going to be very little
consolation uh Lawrence because I think
we're going to see a rook appearing on
E8 any second now
yeah and Matthias just
what can we say Paul mates just just not
able to
to keep up with the big boys in this
tournament just struggling so much
um and
you know he'll take something away from
this it'll be good experience for him so
let's see in the future if he manages to
uh to grow
of course bluebound was part of this
very uh well-known project in Germany
called the German princes project where
the German Chess Federation invested a
lot of money into clearly very talented
young Germans and he was part of a group
of young German players which have all
now become very strong Grandmasters
um and he's top of the list basically uh
in that sense so congratulations to to
him for at least you know he's around
around about 26 70 he's still young he's
still got room to improve so hopefully
he doesn't take this too much to heart
this tournament because it is a brutal
tournament
yeah it really is you just don't catch
any breaks and I think he might resign
Here and Now Hikaru has taken a
different approach and he's instead gone
for the D5 Pawn using the fact that the
BlackRock is pegged to the f-file this
is results of the game is not in
question look at ikar's time management
12 minutes on the clock just uh
you know incredible all the way for for
Mr Nakamura
um and yes nepo indeed has one uh has
lost his game to Notre Beck you've
mentioned that look at that final
position that Rook on E2 the queen on A3
just total total Destruction by the use
back prodigy
and Magnus in really you know fantastic
control in this position as well I don't
see how fit to save really plans to get
out of this one either looks totally
busto for feder safe
I mean he's done I mean he's pulling
down can't move the Knight can't really
do very much
King is weak
looks yeah I mean I guess I guess his
game is a little bit more exciting than
hikaru's I mean hikaru's game is just
real literally just over
so let's perhaps swing back to the world
champion and watch his technique as he
tries to take down
feta saves resistance both sides have
benefited from the additional five
minutes and you know we're not in a Time
scramble just yet but
I cannot imagine having seven minutes
here with like I could burn seven
minutes on one move
easily
so an unenviable position is an
understatement right it's just a
horrible spot to be in for fed to save
no move improves your position no move
really allows you to hold
and Magnus has got various ways to
improve he can play Queen G7 so then
I've even Queen G5 check a queen queen
trade there is going to be crushing
because the G Pawn will March because
because the white king can never get
safe the queen can even if it really
wants you can even set up some kind of
queen G7 King B6 and put the queen on G2
to avoid any checks on D7 even a queen
and D7 check is met by Bishop C7 so you
can just go Queen G7 Queen G2
immediately
um and then you've got you know Bishop
F4 check you've got all kinds of ways
and at some at some point you just lose
this with
uh with white I see Zero chance to hold
yeah and I would I would take the I
would take the email bar with a grain of
salt I mean plus 2.3 yeah the engine can
probably hold with you know just engine
move after engine move but for a human
this is to be sort of lowest kind of
misery just you know no end in sight the
pawn on A3 is also an integral part of
Black's construction it's keeping
White's King at Bay keeping the Knight
restricted
I mean and to add insult to injury you
have this against Magnus Carlson perhaps
the greatest technician in the history
of the game can be won by Vladimir I
think is about as good as it gets in
terms of white king safety and the last
hurdle by Magnus can he find a way to
get this Queen off of F5 without
allowing Lawrence as you pointed out
counter play with Queen D7
I guess the answer is no so yeah
brutally honest uh no I see I see no way
for photosafe it looks toast
looks toast
for the Russian Grand Master
uh Wesley so I mean I
I you know fair play to yopi he's
he's putting in a performance day I'm
really happy that he's he's still
playing and has a position he can win as
well let's be honest I mean this is not
this is not just a position you you lose
here as as black you can you can try
things for sure in this position
yeah he's got a good night good Pawn
structure White's got that weak Pawn on
B3
exactly I agree I don't see Wesley
losing this to be honest but
I think there's going to be some sort of
a liquidation or repetition
but still a draw against Wesley with the
black pieces and in sort of first match
game good start for jorvar and if he can
win one of these matches Lawrence at
this point for him it's about pride and
if he can win a single match that's
something he can carry forward as a
major confidence boost you know I won a
mini match in the Fisher random world
champion that's a big deal
it's a huge deal it's a huge deal
because he is
you know rated 200 250 points lower than
a lot of this field so
let's see if he manages to do it it'll
be really interesting to see
um bloop I'm about to lose the third
Pawn on H6 and I think that will be the
last straw by the way that's bottom left
you can see that Knight heading to G4
okay that one's over
so that one is over yes
Carlson's still nursing his advantage
and herevar will try to squeeze out a
win out of the tiny pool that he has in
his end game
um
yeah bluebound's still playing he's
still trying but he's dropping all of
his Pawns
I mean he's he's playing on out of
frustration isn't he and queen G7 by
Carlson in the meantime by the way just
to uh to just to uh yeah update you guys
he's going for the plan I I mentioned
before so this looks
very very good indeed
yeah it does it does and I agree with
the point about blue ball playing it out
of frustration if it was the start of
the tournament he would have resigned
already because you stand zero chances
against Hikaru in this position like
literally negative chances
but when you're frustrated and things
aren't going well for you you often you
know
you just you're tilting out windmills
right
um yeah I uh
I I saw this a lot yesterday actually
with with Matisse he played on out of
inertia in in totally dead position so
he's definitely
feeling extremely frustrated at the
moment he's definitely feeling it
uh he has resigned by the way yeah
all right let's I think we should stick
with the photocell Carlson game of
course because yeah because that in
terms of uh
qualifier has been fair to save needs a
miracle here and we want to remind
everybody that Notre back with that win
against Jana pavnishi he's guaranteed
himself at least a tie in the match and
therefore he has clinched top spot in uh
his group just unbelievable performance
by Notre back and he leaves nothing to
chance right off the bat but okay this
is still not totally over Rook C1 fed I
say I'm just curls up into a ball and
basically says hey you're still going to
have to breach the gates to get to my
king So this game is not over and
Carlson has been spending quite a bit of
time here he's down to three minutes
again
well I think Magnus is just trying to
find a construction where you know he he
doesn't get better so I move for example
like King C7 here just to prevent any
checks uh King B6 is also there but King
C7 just prevents any entry by the queen
then you go Queen G5 and then you slowly
March the pawn up the board right that
looks like a fairly sensible way to
proceed I'm sure there are probably
other ways you can go here as well I
just don't know what they what they are
I mean you could even probably go Queen
G5 here but this is not the Carlson
school like if you play Queen G5
then Queen D7 check Bishop C7 and the
point is not night before
because Rook beats your results and
check them but I think here white can
simply take the pawn on A3 and this is
the first step yes to White sort of
unfurling is eliminating that A3 Pawn
that back to C2 and then all of a sudden
night before becomes a possibility so
this is the last thing Carlson wants or
needs as his clock now dips to two
minutes so something is bothering him
maybe about the king C7 move which I
really like I think King C7 is the
clinical way to approach this
totally agree
and a glance over at the clock as he
readjusts the seating position
I think with every ticking second
Lawrence my name might be getting more
and more hopeful he needs a miracle here
he needs this game to go off the rails
for the world champion he needs another
one of those uncharacteristic blunders
that we've seen in this tournament
yeah Magnus had a few blunders but I
think it was a I mean yesterday he it
wasn't the first day he was kind of
making some silly mistakes Queen G3 is
an odd move as well I mean why not Shore
up your king first I know a lot of
people are going to be saying who are
you to talk about Magnus Carlson like
who are you to talk about Magnus Carlson
like this right I get that a lot in
general who are you just a lowly
International master who are you to talk
about the greatest player of all time
and his plans well that's my job
actually
um and you know if if if you don't like
it unfortunately that's just the reality
um
yeah so I I don't I mean I I think
probably he's still well I maybe his
claim is simply that Queen D7 Bishop C7
that was one of the ideas I was
mentioning before right is that Queen D7
uh Bishop C7 exists
um
and for the save trying to manufacture
something but
what are you actually supposed to do
here it's not it's not clear-cut at all
to me basically
well I think okay we should point out
that Queen takes F6 runs into Queen the
threat is Queen takes C3 that is just a
lobster pencer mate in the in the purest
form
uh and if Queen D7 check Bishop C7 white
can in that position play Knight B4
because the black queen has lost contact
with the white Rook but black is spoiled
for Choice there the queen could drop
back from G3 to D6 remember the bishop
will have moved to C7 or or you could
drop back to G6 with a check and push
the pawn to F5 and extend a sixth ranked
defense to the pawn on C6 so I think one
of those lines is in fact what Magnus
was spending so much time calculating on
the previous move and fedesaf is not
rushing with Queen D7 I don't really see
an alternative for him I think he needs
to go Full Tilt you know last chance use
the queen in the night try to
manufacture some sort of miracle
agreed
he has to do something offensive he
can't just sit back and be passive in a
position like this he will get destroyed
so
but again I I you know I think a really
informed Magnus would have played King
C7 you know just totally cut out all you
know all of the White Checks just
totally prevent any chance it doesn't do
it for the save it looks like he played
Knight before immediately right played
night before immediately a trade no but
this is
and here Magnus clearly sees something
now Queen D7 is obviously it's not even
really a thread because black has Queen
C7 but
Magnus drops back to C7
straight away
I feel like there must have been some
sort of a major and the eval bar
confirms this
but I don't see exactly what it was
apparently the winning move was King up
to B6
which is just prophylactic Lawrence this
is in your style the point is that the
moment the queen leaves the diagonal
check and queen C3 try this on for size
is a beautiful but basic data
construction something Magnus should see
uh in you know in in the blink of an eye
Rook H1 is it back Rinker again that A3
Pawn is The Mastermind the criminal
mastermind of all of these mating
constructions but Magnus a more
conservative approach Queen back to C7
and can fit a save grab the pawn on F6
what exactly is wrong with that oh Queen
H7
and then Queen C2 oh that's a beautiful
that's a geometry there well done that's
a beauty and the King hides away on A6
wow yeah that's that's really pretty
and we might see something like that as
well we might really see something like
that
but I think Vladimir could probably
preemptively hide away on A1
or even move the Rook away but I don't
see exactly where maybe something like
rookie one the point is you have to keep
the queen on this diagonal you cannot
allow the king to be driven to A1 under
most circumstances
so Queen e six
oh
now this is getting a little complicated
Lawrence because if black does this
queen H7 Queen C2 thing the White Queen
jumps into D7 and when the quarters are
close King A6 doesn't work because of
Queen CA with perpetual
so Magnus kind of struggling here as
this clock dips down to a minute
yes indeed
trying to find the way maybe uh maybe
had a late night in Reykjavik uh it's
possible
um as far as
Queen H7
okay
yeah see on camera King A1 what is his
follow-up though is it Rook C2 Rook C2
played yes
yeah
Rook F1 or rookie one
and then black still can't quite get
away with Queen H2 again this queen D7
business
leads to perpetual
Vladimir still in the game
rookie one played
47 seconds for the world champion
he's a little bit nervous here Lawrence
not to read too much into the body
language I'm trying not to do that as
much but 35 seconds and nothing
immediate here
I think he's getting a bit frustrated
basically that he can't find a clean way
he knows in his heart
that there there has to there has to
have been a clean way in fact but he
just can't seem to find it and that's
that's frustrating him clearly
Rook H2 okay
well
also looks favorite Paving the way but
again Paving the way for Quincy too but
again Queen C2 is never really possible
provided that white screen keeps in
contact with the D7 square that is a
huge problem for black how do you solve
it maybe you don't solve it and you just
start pushing the F on your old idea I
mean you do have an extra Pawn the black
hasn't tapped into yet
right
oh wait a second oh cool can you try
Queen F6 and if Queen C2 you can give
away both of your heavy Pieces by four
no still me no I think he can take on F6
doesn't do it though
yeah I don't know what is wrong with
Queen takes F6 no I look like he's
winning somehow but I think it was a
good try
I think it was a very good try
unlucky
good spot yeah Queen up an F6 instead I
don't see exactly what he did they've
repeated moves they've traded Queens no
they haven't they haven't
Rook G2
are also just sort of biting his time
and I still think you can take on F6
I think you probably I mean he should
probably try it right I don't see any
benefit of not trying it let's put it
like that
I think I see what the issue is after
Queen takes F6 Queen H2
Queen H2 and if you give rookie seven
checks somehow the king hides on B6 and
The Rook cuts off the Queen's axis to d8
no I I think that's what Carlson is
relying on with his last nine seconds
that makes a lot of sense
so I guess you should just keep moving
his Rook back and forth for the time
being
he's taking an F6
no he missed it
oh my gosh did that really just happen
how do you miss queen H2 that is just
did that really that is Elementary
School
did that really just a Magnus disgusted
with himself
but I I can't get over the fact that he
missed this I mean he saw the stalemate
it's it's just about missing queen H2
uh and after Queen H2 it's over it's
mate
wow what a throw this is unbelievable
really this is just insane stuff
again inside you know I would not have
been able to handle the pressure nearly
as well but huge kudos to fetusa first
and foremost he needed a miracle he got
a miracle
but this is just we don't see this from
the world champion like ever
uh automatically
this this has left me a bit choked I'll
be honest with you I'm I'm kind of lost
for words here
but we have one more game remaining by
the way yeah let's let's discussed yeah
the surrog Radisson game and yopi
is he holding is he winning what is
going on here he is close to winning
he's trying to promote a pawn look at
this position how does Wesley stop the C
Pawn the sea Pawn is running
the sea Pawn is running the C Pawn is
running white has to find a way to
counter promote the h-spot I think the
king away yeah you go King G6 Knight A4
H6 c2h7 you both Queen and then you try
and win the F5 pawn and and make a draw
but black and trade Queens there it's
like tempo for Tempo I don't see what
the evaluation is
okay there we go and he's about to do it
no they Wesley has found a way
to win the F5 father this is just a draw
yeah this should be a draw now yes this
should be a draw you would expect listen
I think greterson has to be careful
because if you allow a queen trade white
yes an active passwords might actually
promote
that's true actually maybe 94.
goodness me 94. I would hate to defend
this as white though I mean 94 looks
like a lovely move just centralizing the
night putting some pre and he's played
it he's played it almost no time on the
clock juicy
now but Queen B2 I mean the king is
never going to be able to escape yeah
never you say that there was the game
yesterday between uh
um okay
I heard it was Wesley doing I heard an
ooh
I mean now now why there's no chicks
oh my gosh is Wesley playing with fire
G5
but somehow White's King is safe
two seconds make a move
whoa
is that King safe it looks horrible to
me
well Queen E5 Queen E5 no Queenie five
Queen H7 King G4 yeah I think that holds
and
Queen B A
okay
how did he blunder oh my God
how did he blunder mate Queen B8
Queen beings the blunder he had to go
Queenie five oh because that would have
pinned the Knight instead it allowed the
Knight to jump into F2
um honestly so beside himself because
it's a critical game for him it is and
not only that
okay so debrief debrief first of all
shocking moment here Lawrence Queen B2
check Perpetual go home just draw yes
that's it no way to escape what are you
doing going G-Force King E3 suddenly no
more checks no problem G5 Queen F5 Queen
E5 is the only move because after Queen
H7 King G4 you can't move the Knight the
king is safe but instead Queen B8 Queen
back to H7 Knight up to F2 and queen H3
and yes it's a Time scramble but you
just never see this kind of stuff from
the top guys what a crazy start to the
day Lawrence
action action action everywhere let's do
a quick review of the results perhaps
Dania oh my God yeah
so the smoothest game was Hikaru as
usual Hikaru avoided all the drama
yes Hikaru did avoid all the drama uh
all the other games were crazy crazy
absolutely crazy
wow what again uh what a start I mean if
that's the action we've got for today
then then that's incredible
um and yeah
and we're just getting started yeah
we're just getting started I mean every
single game the the the the Carlson uh
blundering into stalemate Hikaru was
just smooth that wasn't really a
drama-filled game at all nope same with
Abdul saturov apart from the slight
slightly being worse out of the opening
he then completely controlled things but
gretz I said fair play to Hoppy I'm
really happy for him I really am I mean
Fair played him for for finally getting
a victory he deserves it he's grinded
hard and I'm over the moon and actually
now Matthias is the only player yet to
win a game hopefully he can score one
that would be really nice as well yeah
no matter you know who you root for you
got to be happy for greterson that was
an incredible finale and don't go
anywhere because if this is how the day
starts and how is the day going to end
and this day is possible of course
thanks to our sponsor brave brave means
private browsing and so much more by
default Brave blocks ads and trackers on
every page and video you visit even on
YouTube no ads means up to three times
faster page loads faster streaming and
faster playback it means 35 longer
battery life while saving on mobile data
and internet bandwidth or Android iOS
and desktop thank you to Brave for their
sponsorship of these Fisher random World
Championships from Iceland what an
incredible start to the day ladies and
gentlemen we are going to go on a short
break refill our coffees catch our
breath and we advise you to do the same
keep your seat belts on because the
Fisher random World Championship
presented by Brave returns with the
second match game on the other side of
this short break
well done okay
what's up man hey just solving some
puzzles
for coffee
shoot
which one is that is that our new one
yeah
I can't get this one man
oh shoot
what's wrong with you man
this is hard
you sure you're feeling okay
uh one
got it oh shoot
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
Hall at the hotel Natura in Reykjavik at
the Fisher random World Championship are
chess.com coverage is presented by Brave
and before the second match game starts
a quick look at the prizes Lawrence
these are mouth-watering numbers 150k
is at stake for the top prize and
everybody gets something generous which
I love to see
yeah it's nice I mentioned this on the
stream yesterday even the even you know
for somebody like uh Matthias or
gretison let's let's use gretison as a
real example here for him to be able to
have a shot at these kind of prizes is
is massive for him
um he does have a full-time job I think
he's a lawyer actually I don't think
he's been chest full-time yeah I don't
think he's playing chess full time at
the moment although of course that could
could be uh could be incorrect I I
haven't spoken to him in a while
but nonetheless uh you know clearly
uh you know massive prizes and the
matches have already started I
understand
yes sir they have and I flipped on the
Carlson feta save game
uh to start what a ridiculous finale we
saw in that one it was a Surefire win
for Magnus it was a classic game by the
world champion
Vladimir fetus is a magician for pulling
out that stalemate trick at the end he's
given himself a new lease on life and he
has to try to capitalize Lawrence on the
psychological Edge that he is
experiencing right now he is back from
the dead he's got a clean slate and he
has to try to get off to a better start
in the opening I think that is a must uh
the position he got in the last game
just wasn't passing muster
no it certainly was and we're going to
need to see an improvement there 100 so
I'm I'm curious to see
uh how these ones set out and uh where
do you want to go first Dania
yeah let's let's uh check out the Magnus
opening
um and then we'll go to hikara afterward
so a Scandinavian
Scandinavian in the Carlson feather say
again we remind you that they have
obviously the same position as they did
in the first match game so that both
sides get to experience it with both
colors so the queen is out early
and the queen makes another move
dropping back to E2 I think Carlson is
trying to get the queen of E2 the bishop
to G2
I kind of like the setup Lawrence I
think it's pretty harmonious and now
black screen is kind of left out of the
party
yeah totally totally agree with you
there um I like this very much uh
the the bishop performs a great job over
on the on the long diagonal what are you
doing with this queen not clear at all
to me what are you doing with it yeah I
mean and and I think this is a very
interesting uh example of obviously
violating quote unco violating the basic
opening rules but in Fisher random you
often have to identify the pieces that
are going to be most problematic and try
to activate them first so Magnus takes
on his chemistry homework first you know
before playing Blitz on chest dog like
he takes care of the hardest task at
first he does his laundry in the morning
the queen is active and now you can
focus on all the other pieces a lot of
I'm afraid to say I'm starting to regret
procrastinating on that
yeah no Magnus is better
out of the open no question no question
about it not even close
hikaru's game has got very interesting I
see out the corner of my eye here as
well we saw something very similar as
well yesterday
um believe it or not in this an early
Bishop to the wing again it's it's a
it's a funky move to a certain extent
it's
uh it's it's a it's an interesting move
at least
um where you where you move this bishop
out we sorry I mean it was a different
configuration yesterday nonetheless it
was played uh yeah and you prove you
provoke a weakness and then go Bishop F7
I mean this is just
uh do you understand anything about
Chess you look at this and you say okay
I just know I just don't understand
chess basically
yeah it's it's a weird one I'm gonna
pull up that game here and this is the
Hikaru game
um blue bomb has the white pieces in
game two
and when you're talking about Lawrence
comes on move four
where Hikaru Nakamura plays Bishop E8 to
H5 attacking The Rook provoking F3
blunting the queen and dropping back to
F7 attacking A2 by the way something
that I've seen blundered a lot uh even
in high level Fisher random games these
Pawns in the corner that result in
trapping The Rook it's such an unusual
Arrangement because you're so used uh to
a Pawn on A2 being Untouchable because
of B3 that there's like weird cognitive
dissonance but the German Grandmaster
spots it and Knight B3 Knight B6 is on
the board
so what do you make of this position
I mean
yeah I think I think black is slightly
better I think the bind you have over
these Central squares is is kind of
relevant so
uh I don't like the queen on H1 if you
ever have to get it out with a move like
F4 then you weaken E4 massively
yes yeah it's too ugly for words so I do
like what habaru has done here does he
do I like it how does he do it so how is
he already better with black after move
seven it's just unbelievable he just
makes this one maneuver Bishop H5 Bishop
F7 poof he's already better already .7
just moved his Pawns in the center like
how bad could that be
it does it does make you wonder doesn't
it
um it really does make you wonder
just special isn't it
it is special when he's in good form he
just you just can't play him like you
just
he's just such a buzz side it's
unbelievable yeah totally agree
uh let's let's go let's go to well
Wesley so is is clearly uh feeling
belligerent after that loss and he's
going for it to for one of a better word
he is uh punting Harry down the end of
the board here
um and rightly so uh because
uh he needs to win to tie this mini
match and in that group
this is actually a crucial spot for
Wesley I mean he still has a chance
because napomnishi is now a dog to lose
and gets zero points against abdisoturov
so even a point here for Wesley will be
really really huge uh to close the gap
in that group
yeah and I mean that last game was such
a heartbreaker because like had he made
that one move Queen B3 and let's be
totally honest that was an obvious move
and on form Wesley would have played
that move
any day of the week Queen B3 end game
you're basically winning no risk instead
he not only fails to win he actually
loses the game so right now he's in
crisis mode greterson is more confident
than has been this entire event hey I
have a win under my belt I all I need is
a draw to win my first match Wesley's
the one uh who has to worry about
remaining in contention so these first
couple of moves are super super
dangerous time for Wesley and I already
like the Iceland Grandmasters position
at night on C5 well placed there's Harry
there goes Harry
but Harry cannot compensate for the
weakness of this F5 score we saw this in
some of the other matches I think in the
Nakamura bluebound first game
yeah uh probably a bit too over eager to
get back on the scoreboard here Wesley I
mean I like the spirit I like seeing
Wesley play like this I'd like to see
Wesley play like this in general a bit
more classical sometimes exactly I feel
like in classical tournaments Wesley
often takes a very low variance route
and that kind of stops him from winning
a lot of these events unfortunately
because uh you know you need to risk it
for a biscuit sometimes he's very
risk-averse is is Wesley so
um so I do like the spirit but as you
said the Knight on C5 here just looks
tremendous for for hopping wouldn't it
be great for him to get a two-nil
victory as well you claws ringing
through the playing Hall if that were to
happen so uh
you know I I am a big I uh gret arson
fan he's such a nice guy as well so
let's see he really is
no it's it's always great to see you
know the the lower rated participants
Strike Back uh and score a nice victory
okay Rook D6 by Wesley a strange looking
move and I think it's quite clear that
he's trying to set himself up for a long
Castle so he wants to Castle queenside
but that Rook is really in the way of
everything it's just sort of trampled
trampled on by all the other pieces and
now the Knight on C5 is even safer than
before because the bishop has lost
contact with it
so my inclination would be to bring the
light squared Bishop out
cover that F5 score instead gretison
goes Bishop to D2 also good attacking G5
and I mean Lawrence with black LAX
pieces not very well developed Wes is
just gonna have a hard time holding his
Queen side together I guess that's the
king side technically yeah
to know what side it is yeah I know
whatever side the king is not on right
now that's the side Wesley has to be
very careful to hold on to and he does a
bishop f8 to H6 and maybe okay he wants
to play jafua uh maybe some uh
precisely what is better very good I've
been waiting for one of those uh I know
eventually okay about I was keeping it
bottled up for a while but you know the
genie the genie will eventually come out
of the bottle Genie does come out
eventually
let's go to another game I'll let you
pick uh wow
I'm just looking at the corner of my eye
here looks absolutely wild as you would
imagine I mean okay chaos
let me think about this I think I'm
gonna pick up the story of an apology
that's top right of your screen here and
the bird's eye view you can see Black's
Queen from h8 to E5 it has gone let's
zero in on that game and figure out
what's happening outerbeck has the
wiping motorbeck is worse he is much
worse why
does it feel like he's made about half
as many moves as Jan has
I mean like where are his pieces
totally agree it's been a complete
complete uh
just meltdown in this opening I mean I
don't know how how else quite to call it
it's been a catastrophe that's opening
for white another grub he played the
feather save opening G4 F4 but this is
just bad Laura I mean G4 F or E4
uh Notre back uh development yeah
something that mere mortals like to do
sometimes yep
gross oh and Bishop C6 and G5 carving
out the E5 Square for the queen an
amazing move by nepo and you just this
is the last kind of position that you
want against the anupam Nishi give him a
huge initiative massively to development
and it's not even a sacrifice he's gonna
win the pawn back on G5 on demand
okay great yeah this is this is not what
you want uh this is and this is also not
really stylistically something that I
think uh Abdul sirov particularly likes
doing he kind of finds weird ways in uh
are these kind of hopeless positions I
mean I I can think of at least three
hopeless positions he's had where he's
turned them he's turned them around and
won
um in critical spots but at the same
time at some point his rock is his Rock
his luck his rock is gonna lung out
his Ruckus gonna let out
yeah it it feels like one of those ones
um so yeah
um but yeah this is gross so we can move
on but nepo in in control here
uh but no you're right though yeah let's
go to Magnus but but just to add to your
to co-sign your point about Notre back
pulling out these losses I mean this is
a Hallmark of these young players just
their resourcefulness uh their tenacity
is just otherworldly I mean they just do
not die and this game is not over the uh
first spot has been clinched by
notorbeck but let's not forget in the
last game he was also quite a bit worse
out of the opening so we'll keep an eye
on notorbeck's attempts to get his
pieces out and uh quash the fire of
Black's initiative but on we go to the
bird's eye view here uh for a moment
Carlson's game is on the lower right of
your screen
and I don't know what must be going
through magnus's mind right now I mean
he's probably telling himself geez like
I just can't catch a break
uh in this tournament and yet he's still
in pretty Prime position to qualify if
he defeats fedes in the second match
game
yeah he is
um you know uh Magnus is one of those
players who I mean let's let's be honest
what what could Magnus attribute his
enormous success to well partly yes it's
because he's an enormous Talent of
course but it's his mental toughness and
bouncing back when he's had a tough loss
or it's you know something he he manages
to just kind of get it out of his mind
very very quickly I think Fabi is
another guy who's able to do that I
think there are some top players who who
struggle with that though
um so you know
curious to see for sure
um this particular game looks as though
Magnus got another I think though if
Magnus blows another really good
position there then we might see liftoff
uh there then we might actually see
a couple times yeah a few a few uh score
sheets scrunching uh stuff in the uh in
the video so
um yeah uh but uh
you know Magnus very very resourceful
and can calm himself reasonably well
looks good there I better say the
position doesn't look great doesn't look
good
you know it's it's you know it's it's
it's it's it's okay I I think it's good
for white I think black's Queen is in a
little bit of trouble here that last
move Knight C5 is very opportunistic I
think Carlson is uh tossing caution to
the wind here and let's pull up an
analysis board I want to show uh what
happens if Vladimir you know keeps uh
keeps going like nothing is the matter
let's just make a couple random moves H6
Carlson wants A3
then he can for example bring the queen
up to D3
and already he is ready to play B4 and
trap uh the black queen but obviously
Vladimir has not won but two Tempe to do
something about it and the most
straightforward way I think that he can
address this mechanism is to try to get
this Knight on C5 off the board and that
is precisely what he does just as I say
that he has played the move Knight B6 to
A4 extremely logical get off me he says
to the C5 Knight and he's vacating a
pathway back to B6 for the black queen I
don't like Knight c5lords I think that
was overly
Superficial by Magnus I think that was
another sloppy move
and it's beautifully punished by
Vladimir he's back yeah back on track
here
yeah he is
um yeah you can't really do much about
this queen right if you go A3 Queen goes
somewhere it's not not the end of the
world basically is it
um yeah maybe a bit too over eager by
Magnus very possible uh
but we'll see a long way to go in this
one
yeah but you can almost you can sense
the frustration in the way that he's
playing I agree that we take his
consistency for granted we take it
completely for granted and it's honestly
unbelievable how consistent he is yeah
regardless of his form I think the
greatest players are able to mask
bad form
through sheer willpower and through
consistently objective play but just in
the way that he's playing here it seems
to me that Magnus is flustered Queen
comes back to B6 still white is doing
completely fine I mean Knight A4 and
Rook D3 if you want to keep it simple
maybe he'll drop the Knight back to D3
and fedesaf still has some problems uh
with his central control his lack of
central control which could hamper his
ability to keep the queen side
initiative going
totally agree
um don't go B4
whatever you do don't go B4
under a royal Fork on C3
that's the sort of thing that can happen
by the way that's not completely insane
for that to happen uh a lot of
hallucinations with these positions
because of the unconventional placement
of the pieces
um you sometimes just miss easy tactics
as well that that has happened
oh yeah oh
what else is going on okay
here let's go to our bird's eye view for
uh for a hot second uh and just maybe
assess summarize all four boards and
then we'll decide where to go so top
left we have
greaterson with a clear advantage
against Wesley so that last move B3
restricting Wesley's night on B6 to the
right is notabeck struggling to get his
pieces out against nepo bluebound
solidly worse against icaro and we just
looked at Carlson's game so blue box
position actually looks a little bit
more interesting than before Lawrence we
can also go to the nepo game uh what's
what's tickling your fancy here
oh the let's go to the nepo game
something just happened tonight took on
D5
and
if you look at your bar
it's it's not loving that it's not
loving that at all is it
well what I would be loving is a
Checkmate on A2 but I think Notre back
would not be loving that I don't think
we're going to be seeing that in this
game let me I think I can I figured out
what the problem is the problem is that
there's no threat so let's say white
makes a neutral move like Knight B3 or
actually
the reason I said that is after Knight
C3 BC white vacates an escape Square for
the king
but I guess the threat is
Queen takes C3
no what am I saying what is the threat
there must be something here is it just
Knight F4 or Knight D3
yeah I guess it's just Knight F4 and
there's too many threats
so for example a natural mover is just
go Bishop G3 right because you cover F4
you hit the queen
right okay
and then if Queen takes G5 remember
you've now got this special move castles
short
oh
oh that's a game
I think that's what he missed and
suddenly F7 is hanging Rook F5 is in the
air
it's just it's just bang bang stuff it
really is
and all of a sudden nepo's the one with
no did all but he's playing it
it's another turn around he's turning
around again and he's done it in four
moves we just had this position we were
administering the last rights Queen F1
night before
already a step in the wrong direction
because it lets notabeck get his night
out NEPA was banking on the Knight D5
move
Lawrence he forgot the Waikiki Castle
he forgot that White Castle at kingside
and that's that is the that the the
Castle's move
in Fisher random is the move that it
changes games in my opinion oh it is
just the move that makes the big
difference because you forget that it
exists sometimes and
let's see if it I think there's a really
great chance that it happens as well it
will well Depot has to move the queen
because if he plays Knight takes C3 then
obviously you don't take the queen and
get smothered mated you play PC and
again the point is that the B2 square is
now available to the white gang and here
the knight uh is obviously lost so
Jan is this is going to be so tilting
there's nothing more tilting than having
the king in your clutches and God flying
down and grabbing you in a helicopter
and lifting you up from the war zone so
that's a nice that's a nice one Daniel I
mean that was poetic uh I don't know
where like I don't know where that came
from I don't know you know deus ex
machina I remember from my high school
days
yes
um
so this is literally deus ex machina the
king just
somehow jumping on like Daenerys jumping
on the dragon and flying away I love it
okay enough Game of Thrones references
calm down
all righty
so let's say queen 65 on the board Here
We Go drum roll please Castle's short
happening now
have you ever like you mentioned lifting
your king and putting it from C1 to G1
like over the board how how cool that
must be to execute that move well it
must be extreme it gives you this is
what I'm saying there's there's a
there's an aesthetic element to it
there's a there's there's something
about just moving that King right which
has to be very very pleasing
so yes there it is
done it Castle short and white is
officially out of the woods
now Black's the one in the woods
just one move
and everything changes quite outstanding
uh let's go to another game perhaps uh
okay yeah and it's clear should we
where should we go let's go back to the
Hikaru game um we first have our bird's
eye view let's let's go Hikaru and then
maybe her bar
um because we we definitely have to give
him some love after that incredible
turnaround in the previous game but on
we go first to the Hikaru Nakamura
game he has the black pieces against
Blue bomb 10 minutes to the good
or Nakamura and he's about to win the D5
Pawn
precisely yeah
whip up some counter play
what is he supposed to do here I mean I
have a fight yeah
any night move looks looks tricky
um how about this very go on wow what
oh my gosh it almost works I was
thinking Knight H5 let's bring up an
analysis board because it is a cool idea
Knight E5 I thought maybe okay four
and okay
yeah but that is Knight D2 is check and
then you have Knight B6 or but only
moves because of DC
no there's not it's being covered yeah
crap yeah no but Knight B6 just holds
everything together because why not
literally has no yeah nothing nothing
further so never mind
blue buff has played instead the move A3
okay counter attack in the night and now
if Knight takes D5 then you do lose A7
at the end and then it's actually
impactful so Hikaru I think has to play
GF
and then maybe Matthias is okay
could be very well but yes
no it looks looks looks very unclear
this position to me I I can't I can't
quite get my head around this one I have
to say
anytime you have two nights hanging like
this it's always going to be a
you know messing with your mind but it
looks pretty normal this might be the
most normal
seeming position we've had all day
okay yeah it takes you Desperado
of course this move is possible whoa
whoa nice jeep
oh
oh it traps the knife
oh whatever no what a movement yes we we
do it we do a move of a move of the day
Dania that that might just be that might
be
that is yeah what's on what's on the
line holy smokes
that is one of the rarest Concepts I've
seen in terms of trapping a Desperado
Knight it doesn't happen every day of
the week
um wow
that's that's
the good news for Hikaru is that he does
have two pawns now for the piece he's
ruined white obviously blue bomb is now
in the best position he's been in all
match long but hikara with two pawns for
the piece and you know I can confirm
from personal experience Lawrence when
you're 10 minutes down against ikaro it
doesn't matter how many pieces you're up
Hikaru can be playing with a single Pawn
you could have your whole Army and
you're still gonna feel like he's out
playing you so yeah Matthias has his
technical work cut out for him but let
me just show that one more time why is
92 necessary well the knights only
Escape square is E3 Hikaru assumed that
white has to capture on C2 and then
everything works Like Clockwork Knight
F4 to G2 covers the square and forces
black to give up is night now blue bomb
moves into D4 let's see if he gets the
Knight out of G2 and towards C4
and this is his best chance to win his
first game of the official random World
Championship
he's gotta capitalize on this
yeah and Hikaru will be sick because
that group is also extremely close
um so ifikaru
loses this he only picks up a point and
prior to today he would have been
thinking blue balm is an absolutely must
win for me in this group so I think he's
going to be very upset at what's
currently going on but you know Hikaru
you've played him what hundreds of times
maybe more about thousands thousands of
times yeah
um this is a guy who finds resources
more than anyone else I know actually in
chess I mean he's incredibly tough to
beat
uh uh so yeah
you know
um no but I'm not I'm not writing him
off just yet let's put it like that
the worst the worst part is when you're
down like this amount of time that's
what worries me the most I think if
bluebound had 12 13 minutes I would have
you know voted for him to win given the
time situation if I had to predict who's
gonna win this game I would probably
assign higher winning chances to Hikaru
than I would to Matthias and this is has
nothing to do with a lack of respect for
Matthias who is a phenomenal player we
talked about him he's great but when you
have six minutes against Hikaru who's
got two piece two pawns for the piece
and you've got a weak King like this
he's gonna find some way to what muddy
the waters right
so today totally understand rookie five
maybe
please foreign but then I guess white
can try out four to
disattach The Rook from the F5 Pawn I
don't know
I don't know he's played rookie five
it's only 0.9 it's not like white is
totally winning or anything I mean the
material advantage is quite Limited
let's not forget that
yeah he covered just incredible I mean
what would you give matthias's chances
of winning this from a percentage if you
had to create a line in this position
for Matthias to win he's probably only
like minus 150 to win this position or
something like that yeah not more than
that I would say if I had to assign
percentages maybe like 20 percent
uh Matthias wins uh 30 draw and 50
Hikaru wins and you think already 50 to
win this you think he's got greater
chances wow
you said Hikaru is actually favorite to
win this I think so and I've seen
because I've seen the narrative so too
many times like you you're sure okay
he's blundered a piece that's it there's
just nothing he can do and then four
moves later your checkmated and uh you
know you just you're looking at your
hands like where did where did all the
gold go where did all my advantage go
Rook C1 though by bluebound he's gonna
pile up on this C7 Pawn which is a
backward Pawn
but perhaps Hikaru could double on the
e-file he's also got 15 minutes to
figure out the best defensive approach
here and that as I said is the most
terrifying aspect of all
yeah uh just not enough time for
Matthias probably but he's he's gonna
make the time control at least this time
because of course we'll move 30 31 he
gets five minutes Etc and then five
seconds per move but you're right I've
also seen it even though I've had
limited experience playing with Hikaru
I've been commentating on Hikaru
watching him play online for literally
20 years now and if I had a pound coin
for every time he salvaged a position
like this
I'd have a lot of pound coins in my
piggy bank
which step over which I would rather
have a lot of dollars and by the way
talking of dollars Dania
I've got to confess something
okay where is
before the the critical moment happens I
didn't know about the two dollar note
I didn't know about it I never owned one
it's a random City I've been to the US
dozens of over a dozen times more than
that much more
I never owned held or possessed a two
dollar note do you own a two dollar note
so I did up until like a month ago and
then I accidentally spent it at the
grocery store I was keeping one of my
wallet
uh it's like you know
the
I was like don't use it don't use it but
then I uh I couldn't resist I love I
love the two dollar note it's such a
cool feeling to to have one so I'm on
the prowl I'm on the prowl for another
one
you get one hold it on hold it hold on
to it for me I'll give you three dollars
for it
give yourself a deal speaking of deals
the car says I'll give you the F4 Pawn
if you give me your D5 Pawn
well what do you say to that that's an
offer but TS cannot refuse because he's
gonna lose the D5 Pawn one way or the
other wow
that's actually brutal because you can
start feeling the momentum go away from
Matthias four minutes left
this is where it gets nasty because
yeah I mean you could take on F4 right
so wait Queen F4 what's the idea to go
Rook f8 Queen somewhere
I think just 95 or just say oh no no it
doesn't work
uh takes takes and queen C4 oh
that's a forkovic
ovic because after Rook D2
sorry go ahead yeah Queen J which take
oh you take kicks excuse me yeah yeah
excuse me so you're absolutely right I'm
wrong I think the idea is in factor a
cafe I stand corrected he's actually
going for the F3 Pawn rather than the D5
Pawn
ah exactly and this could get really
ugly for white Lawrence because the
knights are both undefended they're
unanchored by pawns unmoored from the
position and he carves Rooks are so
active here
hmm
tough stuff 30 minutes for Matthias five
more moves to make until he gets that
additional five minutes
can he pull it off
let's see
let's wait another two moves and then I
do want to get to magnus's game because
I think
we're about to see some crazy stuff
there as well but let's see how blue
bomb handles this next moment
Rook G2 Queen h8 okay
that simply kicks the can down the road
now he's got to move the queen yeah
and where is he gonna yeah
no this is extremely unpleasant totally
totally agree with you uh Dania how
unpleasant this is is is is is no joke
um
yeah and what do you what do you do here
actually
I think perhaps Queen D4 Rook 24 and
then maybe double on the G file because
what the White's main advantage here is
the weak back rank yeah Queen D4 on the
board and maybe Rook G1
just try to squeeze a rook into G8
but Rook G1 Hikaru could I mean he's got
options there rookie one I like I mean I
always like being of offense being the
best form of Defense right uh rookie one
you you probably just go and he does
play well done the test that's good
that's a great move by blue but I'm
keeping his composure thus far
yeah and now Hikaru is gonna I think now
is actually a moment with a 13 minute
advantage on the clock this is a really
critical moment I think Hikaru makes a
mistake here by playing a move way too
quickly because you've got a lot of
ideas you've got Rook f8 you've got
um Queen
yeah d8 exactly blocking
you you
probably that's about it actually you
don't have too many options I do like or
queen E8 yeah to play Rook f8 either or
yeah
and he's played it Queen E8 and he took
some time but not a lot
and now the big move the 30th move for
blue bomb he's got two minutes to make
it
after Queen E8 if one pair of Rooks
disappears from the board then again the
other Rook is gonna have a hard time
holding everything together the eval bar
not the greatest fan of Queenie but it's
a decent move
and I think blue Bob's gonna go Rook G8
and we're gonna see a trade and then the
position is going to stabilize somewhat
what do you think Rook cheater is he
gonna play something else
maybe Knight D2
oh actually 92 is interesting actually
92.90 what what's not and 92 you just
want to distract The Rook away from the
file and then play Rook G8 precise very
curious move yes
yes precisely
exactly exactly
uh Lone Pine okay he's played
rocker fate and move 30 has been made
we're gonna see a trade of Brooks and
bluebird is going to continue trying to
nurture
uh and nurse is advantage
to a conclusion but how is he going to
protect that weak D5 Pawn the undefended
knights his weak King this collection of
factors I think gives secaro excellent
practical chances so we'll keep an eye
on this game let's go to the Carlson
game though because we have some
cataclysmic occurrences in that game a
brief stop at the bird's eye view you
can see
whoa you can see Abdul satorab's rock on
f8 I think he's about to win another
game
yeah abdisaturov is just I mean
napoleonishi has just been blown away by
abdic I by the way if abdisator of wins
this game listen to this
he's won eight games in a row
what eight games in a row yep
oh maybe seven excuse me not if you went
to this game he that's it we don't even
have to go to that position it's over an
order breaks yes look at that Rook on
fade the battery against C7 top right of
your screen
it's over it's it's toast
what the heck 2-0 against nepo yeah
let's repeat it again let's do another
2-0 just to show everybody that wasn't a
coincidence
oh my God I mean
let's go to Magnus yeah but he's about
to when she falls zero is is just
incredible a Magnus is about to win so
this is this is over this is sad for
Vladimir let's rewind a little bit he's
just taken on F7 lack's position is
falling apart at the seams Lawrence with
the queen coming into E7 a knight
dropping back to D6 in the event of Rook
E8 with a fork
uh this is over how did this how did
this go so South for for Valor
well C5
yeah
Magnus sacking a pawn to get his Bishop
out to H3
okay yeah a trade on D7
oh he castles King side and I guess
fedes King just kind of gets caught on
the crossfire here another Pawn sack for
Magnus
but this shouldn't be that bad for black
these two pawns up
[Music]
that's the mistake because now the
knight's coming into G5 the other
night's coming into G5
yeah yeah yeah so Queen C6 I think let
the let the wheels come off
yeah enough to B5 Knight G5 and Knight
takes F7 is that that really is actually
just it right because let's say you go I
don't know like rook f8 in this position
um Rook D6
oh Queen E7
96.
oh Rook D6 yeah 95 is crushing I mean
Queen F6 and a rook takes D7 takes D7
yeah
Bang Bang
Queen D5 check and Knight p7
oh look at you that is clinical bang and
the bang import work again
Queen V8 Knight Queen d896 is also
I mean you can also just take on a fade
because the queen is protected oh no the
queen is protected I was I I actually
saw that because Rook d8 Knight takes F6
both nights protect yeah I think we're
gonna see just that yeah Rock Cafe is on
the board
is also winning
yeah this move just wins straight away
right because if you go I don't know he
goes Rook B8 but now you can just go
Queen anywhere on the defile and you
attack the car or an Ida check after or
96 or any old iron as uh
some English grammars is like to say but
Queen D2 is just that's it clinical yeah
the sad thing is if you play Rook F7
cell aluminum let me at least get
something for the queen at the end of
the line white picks up the Rook with
Queen D5 I think Vladimir is going to
resign in this position yeah
you've got to know when to hold them and
when to fold them vladimirosev going
down in this match and this is what I
was telling you Dania you know a lot of
people after blowing that position in
the last game would have struggled to
get themselves composed not Magnus
Carlsen that's the difference or nope
you know so
just brutal stuff absolutely brutal
stuff
he's just impervious to this guy I mean
there's zero tilt maybe a little bit of
consternation maybe a little bit of
jitters at the start of the game but the
moment he got in in his Groove the
moment he sends sensed weakness he
pounces and that is the nature of
supreme confidence that's what makes
someone like Magnus so scary just
doesn't let anything affect and shake
the way that he plays the next game just
Rises back up for the millionth time
okay so this one's over
we'll probably catch the handshake here
in just a moment
Queen C8 played
all right I think it's time to bring the
curtains down
after Rook takes D7 check
magnus's thing what is he thinking about
he's trying to make it pretty I might be
seeing my queen if I've checked first is
is more precise
uh but I I don't particularly know why
photo save is playing on here
yeah I mean you gotta try right this is
a huge match
Carlson has has had his share of
uncharacteristic Wonder so
I think the decision to play on is a is
a Justified one here okay
oh
I'm trying to find these mating
constructions but I think Magnus should
just win this as unadventuriously as
possible
kind of surprise he's taking this long I
mean what are you thinking about here
just Queen D5 Rook takes D7
he does go Queen D5 the thing is yeah
King B8 Rook D7 you had to account for
Knight B6 and then Queen D6 check
yeah King A8 and I guess just works 67
and
it's not that tough to calculate to be
for no it is not and Magnus good time
management in this game
if King C7 then Rook C6 Jack picks up
the queen of course
yeah yeah
just deciding when to resign here
yeah he's got a little smirk on his face
actually there so uh
yes that is
we're seeing on the preview camera has
won his game
he's discussing with yandupam Nishi can
I flip and show just the end of that
game which was sure I'm gonna
just flat out say it was sexy it was
amazing
so we had this position which is
obviously completely winning but look at
this final combination bang Rook takes
d8 oh forcing the king out of the cage
now the other room comes in
can you see it lovely good move
by nepo check and queen zigzags back to
F7
if Rook D7 then rookie 8 check and queen
takes C7 ends the game
and if the queen defends
if the queen defends then Queen F5 and
her kid is made oh about that one
how about them athols Magnus Carlsen
winning that match and
you know with that win
uh
uh you know if Hikaru
doesn't do the business well
Magnus in great shape to to just uh to
win the group
um
big favorite at least now let's go to
that blue bum game critical yes
important game indeed going on
now
it's unclear and he's down to a minute
again
and this time for the rest of the game
and all he has
to compensate for that is a five second
increment but
bluebound with his last move trying to
get Black's only remaining Knight off
the board and Lawrence if he can manage
to do that
the position becomes easier to play Rook
G8 is not Checkmate because there's
rookie eight
right
and that's exactly what happens and I
still maintain
that at best this is gonna be a drug at
best for NCS you really think white has
got no winning chances here
zero especially now because after the
trade the queen infiltrates to E2 and
wins the H2 fund and then black guy no
now now I totally agree with H2 off the
board
it's going to be addressed completely so
if you think it's a draw
well after Queen H2O I think Matthias
can just start checking queen h8 queen
D4 and if he can induce B6 then the
queen can jump into G7 hey he shouldn't
lose this with a knight like that no
there's also Knight A5 to get to go into
C6 I don't love it because I feel like
I'm gonna blunder something Queen G7
um it says but besides to to attack a
pawn you're right it should still be a
draw
can you believe hikara is 15 minutes
almost 16 minutes
incredible I mean that's just crazy time
difference here I think Queen H3 check
also draws because White's gang will not
be able to hide
or will it
win H3 King B4 Maybe
wait a second
what happens after King B4
King before he has played it
no but yes listen he's he has to he's
going because a draw
loses the match so he's got literally
nothing to lose
huh
this is interesting
somehow the king is safe
can you believe this position
um
the king is safe and and I've got
absolutely no idea King B8 Queen G8
but how does white actually make
progress let's say King a server I mean
what do you want to do here what about a
zigzag Queen f8 and queen E7 trying to
inch my way to d8 okay he gives a check
on D on G8
I guess he wants King A7 Queen d8
God that's scary I mean white could get
mated there somehow
and if a way existed car will find it
I don't see this really going any other
way
well what's the movement
no no but King A7 is dangerous for black
guy Mickey car was seriously
contemplating Quincy and after Queen
takes H7
well then you just sort of wait Queen E8
but after King A7 Queen d8 what is
Black's move
how how do you defend this Pawn
ah
I see this is not happened I'm just
showing this hypothetically so
Queen D3 yeah
ever work
nice if I will take it
and now we've got no decent check to
then check again right that's too
dangerous
that's fine yeah
Queen e no Queen E3 Queen sexy
oh yeah I can't do that yeah and here I
take and I'm windy food check no I mean
we're running for we're taking far too
many risks here this is and we're giving
too many pawns away I think the good
thing about Queen D3 is that you just
simply take on D5 you don't need to
worry about a Perpetual here is just the
draw white is out of Pawns and queen B6
the king is perfectly happy running
between a seven and eight
but that has to be found and he carved
for the first time this game taking a
significant chunk of time and the last
thing he wants to do is you know
unnecessarily drop this game after such
a good defensive effort
yeah
so
yeah this one this one looking like a
draw here greterson and Wesley are still
playing as well and it looks like Wesley
might be able to Rebound with the black
pieces
but we don't have to go to that game
just sort of reporting all the
proceedings
it certainly does uh
let's probably stick to this game yeah
let's stick here because this this is
continuously okay yes his next move I
mean this is interesting he's gone into
the tank yeah
stops hearing you there for a second
Lawrence oh give me a moment keep
talking yeah sorry I was gonna say
uh
he does go King a servant Queen d8 and
now let's see what his response is
no this is this is this is he probably
will go after this D5 Pawn right Queen
D3 Queen 67 Queen 65. and
yeah he's not winning that
unless you you can like Queen H1 is the
same thing because you can I like this
move because you can come to B1 as well
give some um
checks I think he is going to take on D5
yeah because Queen B1 he's still not
hearing you but
oh okay this one seems to be headed sort
of draw
let me take C7
[Music]
oh there we go can you hear me now
yes I can okay uh sorry yeah Queen takes
D5 King B8 yeah and it this does look
like it's now I can't hear you again oh
my goodness me what's going on
now I can we takes D5 okay yeah whatever
up in there now I can now I can hear you
but Queen 65 is just gonna be a prepaid
yep
okay
yep so
so kind of like we predicted I mean
queen H1 is the same type of move as
Queen D3
I can hear you though I think
keep the status quo
yeah this is just going to be Perpetual
it takes D6 I can't actually unmute
myself
but you're I can hear you
okay okay
we need to check
blue Bob has to be careful not to
blunder of Queen here King C5 Queen F2
gives up the queen
so
white has to step very very carefully
here
thing see if we need to if I talk only
Dan you can hear me the people can't
hear me right
I think everybody I think people can
hear you people can hear me excuse me
yeah yeah
I I think you're good we're rolling okay
sorry sorry guys apologies like slight
audio issue
so
this is
as they say in Vladivostok Nietzsche
for uh for one of for one of them yeah
Queen takes a three and I think only
black really is playing for a win there
I agree
take and swing the queen over to D7
start pushing your H Pawn and I've seen
Hikaru win crazier positions than this
for sure
absolutely so what is
Hikaru double checking here is he making
sure that he can get the queen to defend
the B7 Pawn after Queen takes A3
possibly yes he has to find a route
um
let's see what he goes for does take it
he does take it
he's got three pawns for the piece now
and all blue bomb wants is just to draw
at this point
okay King moves there's something back
to D7 go see Karo
blue bomb playing on his last seconds
five seconds oh my gosh what back
okay two G one
okay curious move
interesting the Knight does a great job
it's actually a great move because Queen
E7 King D5 there are no checks for black
the queen on G1
this is actually a brilliant on D6
it really is the 906 kind of acts like
an umbrella
for example if H5 you go Queen GH at
King A7 Knight C8 check Daniel Knight B6
and you win to B6 and this is where he
carves 10 minutes come in so handy he's
got to be careful Queen E7 check King D5
is gonna happen and maybe Queen back to
d8 back to D7 he goes pinning
okay draw
this might be throwing or is he Cairo
gonna do something brazen
it wouldn't surprise me
no but I mean he wins the match
yeah
he wins so much
there's the handshake
that is all that is required
still no win at least
still no wins but he draws from a
position of strength but it really was
never in question like hikara blunted a
piece and it was as though he never
blundered anything at all as he wins
a big mini-match against bluebound let's
switch back to the greterson game
because that is still going it is once
again the last game of this first match
and here we have it
okay greterson I thought was completely
lost but suddenly he's gotten his King
to a very active square and he's got
serious drawing chances
root takes F6 Rook takes A2
do you take y to A6 King D4 or you play
you know you pick up enough is white
even worse
Asics
also
yeah C4 eliminating Black's password is
your idea yeah I guess this is not
technically a passer
but I just feel like it I don't I don't
feel like black can yeah and he plays C4
of course
very good call Lawrence yeah this is a
great so okay obviously black is playing
for a win here because black is up a
pawn and it's not just any pawn it's a
passer on A6 but White's King is more
active
I don't know who yes black is playing
for win but I have to say
I think I'd prefer white in an
over-the-board game think you have to
finding the precise moves here with
black is is not easy at all
um
White's plan is fairly straightforward
I think you're being over optimistic
though what have I take and go Rook F3
I think you are nothing wrong with it
E3 yeah okay I'm gonna take
Rook G3 yeah I go E4
I I see what you're saying I mean that
pawn runs really fast but so does mine
and I guess since Wesley has two and a
half minutes I can make these moves so
what we're analyzing yeah is take Stakes
Rook F3 here here breakthrough
Rook G3 E4
okay
I have to decide we I will go E5 just
for the for the culture
for the walls yeah no here here I agree
you're getting your opponent E6 The Rook
is very nicely placed actually too
yes
okay anyways Rook B6
is Wesley's what an interesting move by
Wesley Rook B6 preparing to push B4 and
essentially forcing White Hand
foreign
fully focused there
and he has not taken on B5 King D4
he's basically saying once
he's saying B4 C5 and he's doing well
and he said k64 King takes C4 no harm
done I'll pick up E4 when I want and
again kind of weirdly prefer white again
that's just a lack of understanding on
my part
so he does too no but I totally see what
you're saying I mean I think obviously
the the objective evaluation here it
should be a draw
there should be some sort of mass
liquidation but it is it is a three
result game and Wesley has to win this
game
in order to
save and tie the match if you're just
joining us a shocking defeat suffered by
Wesley from a position of strength in
the first match game Yoruba wins his
first game of the tournament and now all
he needs is a draw
can he pull it off with a minute and a
half on the clock for both players Rook
B1 King D4
confident play by the Atlanta Grand
Master
yeah I think a minute and a half is
plenty of time here rugby four check you
go King E5 of course
okay then I go King B6 and start pushing
the a pawn
are you sure you want to lock yourself
up six
like gold
King C3 but yeah King C3 might be clever
Rook B5 King D4 and Wesley who can't
make a draw here you can't remember no
he's gonna obviously he has to try
something so he tries A5
King takes E4 will happen and then King
B6 is my prediction
I feel like Wesley's gonna win this I
just get this this hunch that Wesley's
gonna find a way
to squeeze out a win
because the problem yes what about
what's the problem
yeah Rook C2 this is what I was gonna
say now A4 Rook C6 check he's gonna play
King B7 and is he Kevin though and and
now he is he's going to be careful right
because the Rook Gets behind the point
yeah no I didn't like this by shopee
I think he I think he really
misinterpreted Rook c4k5 this is exactly
yeah no that's a bad Square he wants I
think before check but black is more
than happy to tuck his King away on A6
because eventually the white Rook is
going to have to move to total passivity
on the a file and then it's just going
to be winning
yeah yeah now I think it's okay now it's
just over I think and in fact I think
black skin can go either way it could go
around but King A6 is clinical
no he he lost he lost the thread here
or if you are of our
so close so close drawing this one your
instincts were spot on though Daniel you
felt as though
uh he was gonna that Wesley was gonna
squeeze something out and he has uh and
yeah well the game isn't over but it's
really bad because
the white Rook has to go passive
the king walks in it's pretty pretty
standard procedure actually
I think it's actually just resignable
yeah he won't resign he's going to play
Rook B1 A3 Rook A1 A3 uh King B5
and the sad thing is just the structure
on the king side it doesn't cater to it
just doesn't allow white to create a
passer so every Pawn end game is going
to be dead lost yeah you can just go
King C5 here that's what he wants yeah
yeah and now he wants to set up the
famous King takes D5 Rook D1 checking
King A1 so King D6 La class Wesley so
that is the move zook's phone look at
that beautiful move but that's amazing
that's a beautiful move
that's a stunner yeah because now if
you're ever yeah now King takes D5 and
The Rook will have to come back to a one
now this is just Exquisite technique but
so I've seen too many of end games like
this that he's won
you know that's why I had this hunch
he just he's just a buzz side never lets
you go
never lets you go kingy four it's over
yeah
yeah because the king gets two F3 and
Pac-Man's F2 G2
[Laughter]
F2 G3 oh rugby five is class as well
guys
playing with this food he's yeah playing
with his food here King E4 there it is
it's over that Rook on A5 so nicely
placed they also defend the H5 pawn and
a resignation from U of r
unless
and they didn't actually move the name
tags uh for the second game I noticed
but nevertheless
massive point for Wesley so in the
standings because with that
uh extra point he's only
I believe will get the full standings up
just behind
uponishi who got drilled by Abdu Sutter
of seven wins on the bounce in classical
terms in classical points to system
Dania nine and a half out of ten excuse
me against this field he has I'll repeat
nine and a half out of ten points yeah
repeat that like 10 times in a classic
piece that ten
timesheet four games Wesley so
two games
I mean
I'm sorry
if there are chess 960 Fisher random
ratings
he's just well world number one by a
country mile at the moment
uh
I don't know I don't I don't know if
there are anyway
brilliant where's he so managing to uh
survive that minimatch drawing one all
Hikaru managing to not lose a
potentially dodgy looking position but
Daniel was always faithful to Hikaru so
resourceful winning that match and
Carlson
winning one and a half half but the the
score doesn't really tell the full story
really should have been 2-0 for Carlson
he's now in a really great position in
that group but okay Hikaru is also uh
completely fine in that group two looks
as though those two are now massive
favorites as you would expect the two
group favorites feather save is gonna
need a miracle to come through that
group and in group a it's all about solo
nipomnushi
yeah I mean it's just it's just crazy
how consistent these top these top guys
are Wesley
I wouldn't call his match a disaster he
narrowly averted disaster so
let's take a look at the group a
standing so the group is standings Notre
pick wins Wesley basically has a
must-win situation and is Wesley playing
Young
Wesley is playing
in the next one oh that's cool so Wesley
will have to deal up to satorov not only
forget the first loss match loss of the
tournament his first game I mean I'm
just a storm has lost the game Wesley
will have to pull out his a game he has
to step it up Lawrence in comparison to
this match against greenderson because
sort of isn't just yeah whatever I've
clinched it no he's gonna be trying
now for sure well Wesley simply has to
win this match there's no other uh
mathematical formula that works if he
loses his match
he is out as far as I can tell we will
have an update of the standings when we
get back we're just organizing that it's
been an absolutely fantastic first round
so far let's have a look at what we've
got lined up though for round six
because
it is mouth-watering to say the least
let's have a look yeah I mean we have
greters and nepo and you know Wesley
will need greterson to pull out a a
miraculous Victory but nepo could be
tilted Notre back Wesley that's what we
were talking about blue bomb fedes and
the Marquee match up Carl said at
Nakamura which we will be bringing you
uh full coverage of on the other side of
the break before we go to break
don't forget even if you don't know
about this event where have you been the
chess.com Global Championship is coming
to a head in Toronto live finals begin
Wednesday November 2nd yes that's this
coming Wednesday with 500k on the line
who will come out on top after the
upsets we've seen throughout this
tournament it is truly anyone's game do
not miss a minute of the cgc live finals
from Toronto including special guest
appearances from the Fabiana carwana
streaming right here on chess.com if you
want more info Type X Glam cgc finals in
the chat and read up on all the details
what a way that'll be to start November
I'm heading to Toronto on Monday I can't
wait for the cgc finals and I can can't
wait for the next match here in uh
chess.com's coverage of the Fisher
random World Championship brought to you
by Brave do not go anywhere keep your
seatbelts fastened and we will be back
with Magnus ikaro and other amazing
matches in just a couple of minutes
the only thing better than chess is more
chess so don't miss a moment of the
Fisher random World Championship or the
women's candidates we will be Squad
streaming both events so you don't have
to pick just one simply click this
button at the bottom of our streaming
panel to watch multiple events at once
click again to switch back to a single
screen don't miss a moment of top level
chess with Squad streaming on twitch.tv
chess
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the Fisher random World
championshipartchess.com coverage
brought to you by Brave and it is time
for our brave move of the day we had
some incredible matches this was a
difficult choice but at the end of the
day we have to give some cred to Mr
abdisator of for his beastly play this
is a position that you will hopefully
remember for a while Lawrence Jan has a
massive attack going whites King is
caught on the crossfire it's over it's
Checkmate there's no way out of it wait
a second Bishop G3 no problem attacking
the queen queen takes you five and
Lawrence I'll toss it to you to reveal
our brave move of the day in this
position
well exactly and we said it was possible
that we'd see a long castles and when we
talk about lung castles in chess often
it's the king going to the queen side
but not in this position and not in
Fisher random because in this position
with the back rank now cleared you can
play the move King to G1 castles
which is Then followed by The Rook
coming to F1 one of the stunning
resources that exist in Fisher random
and all of a sudden the complexity and
the dynamic of the position changes the
white king gets safe it's very unsafe on
C1 the white Rook gets active down the f
file and all of a sudden after being in
a in bad shape white is now much better
and went on to win the game brilliant
stuff by the young Uzbek star
he is so resourceful and this is but one
of just so many incredible moments from
uh his tournament thus far and that
ladies and gentlemen Was Your brave move
of the day it's time to make your move
from chrome to Brave try it now at
brave.com today okay well let's debrief
a little bit before the second position
is revealed we have here the match
results from the first match of the day
a great match for greterson all things
considered Lawrence I mean he'll take it
obviously almost saving that second game
still uh getting uh throwing a wrench in
the works uh to Wesley so who is
obviously relying on winning this match
just shows you that all these guys are
incredibly strong can't take anything
for granted but the star of the show
obviously is Notre back another 2-0
victory
just
um
speechless really uh you know just
beating Top Class Elite Grand Masters
for fun showing his natural Talent his
natural
uh prowess for this game and he was
already a lock before today but now he
really is winning this group and it's
important to win this group
because I guess he wants to avoid Magnus
uh that being said it's not as if he has
avoided Magnus because as we can see in
group b they are tired at the top
Carlson and Nakamura and in fact they
are both through aren't they because
there's one game one match remaining
today as far as like yeah remember and
with only one match of course you can't
overtake so it's just a question now of
Group B who is going to win the group
Carlson or Nakamura so this this match
is relevant Carlson playing Nakamura so
it will be decided uh between these two
Giants and then whoever finishes second
will face nordebec and the second spot
in group a is the one the only thing
that is UN undetermined yet could still
go either way
yeah that is the standings related
Intrigue that we will be monitoring as
Wesley so uh that draw was very painful
because he falls a point behind beyond
the promissory now Jana has a good
pairing All Things Considered he's got
greterson that's a match that he
obviously is hoping to win uh that's a
match that he should win if he
demonstrates good form but in that last
match greterson showed that he is
absolutely no pushover uh and you know
you give him enough chances he is going
to sting but Wesley Wesley has a
nightmare match against Abdul satorab
and Lawrence I think it's safe to say
you can co-sign me on this just because
notrebrecht has now clinched first place
doesn't mean that his effort is going to
diminish if anything the lack of
pressure might make him uh even more of
a beast in this last round so Wesley's
work cut out for him big time
well it is because after always just
playing at a level that is simply
uh unchallengeable you you can't play
with the guy who's winning seven games
on the bounce against these Top Class
Grand Masters simply put Wesley so needs
a bit of luck he needs I have to settle
to have a dip in form we can see players
there by the way the playing Hall uh a
lot of the seconds are there you can see
big Peter heiner in the background just
there who else have we got Wesley Mateus
yep
uh they
they're all waiting on the position to
reveal and the position has just been
revealed
it's a bit like a gender reveal right
Daniel it's just like a gender yeah
exactly
let's watch it yeah
yeah we're looking here at the Players
as they're looking at the big screen on
which will be projected the position
that will be contested in this second
match will obviously be different from
the first position and it will be
different from the starting position of
regular chess so where is the king gonna
be where is the bishop gonna be as we're
looking at the world champion getting
wanted
suspension wouldn't it be funny drum
roll suspense wouldn't it be funny if he
started bleeping and they've they found
something on his person uh that would
that would make quite the story
yes it would the Chess World has been
too quiet recently I think we need a
little infusion a little drama infusion
as Peter Heine shares a smile there with
the world champion you can see Hikaru
Wesley greterson all there standing in a
row
and
that's great changing no position yet
and it's getting revealed now a bishop
in the corner
and a queen next to it
and what's gonna be on C1 the Rooks Rook
and here's another Bishop
a knight oh okay and another night okay
all right this is unique in the King of
The Rook okay round off the back row
again the kings are kind of already
castled we're gonna spend a little bit
of time trying to make some initial
observations about this position so we
can come in with a somewhat informed
understanding of what's going on
Lawrence your sort of instinctual
reactions as we look at the Players
heading toward the playing Hall with a
position in their mind
yeah this one is as you said a bit more
normal because in in the past few
matches it seems as though the King has
been wedged between two Rooks
um so this is uh this is gonna be
interesting
um
it feels as though you're gonna get
slightly more Orthodox positions from
this setup
uh the two knights though make an
impression on E1 and F1
I don't quite yeah they really do
yeah I can imagine this one actually
having a bit of central control is going
to be useful because for example if you
move the E and F pawns and try and get
the knights behind them you're gonna
you're gonna have some central control
there so that could be an idea but again
just surely
hypothesizing here absolutely no idea
yeah and the best way is I think it'll
just take a couple of minutes for us to
adjust our eyes to this position and
that is why we're gonna go on another
break the players have approximately 50
minutes uh to to make some initial
analysis talk the position over with
their seconds prepare their initial
moves and when we come back we are going
to take a deeper dive into the position
using an analysis board we're actually
going to dip dig deep and see if we can
predict what kinds of first moves the
players are going to be likely to essay
so ladies and gentlemen do not go
anywhere we've got some incredible
matches coming up for you here at the
Fisher random World Championship the
chess.com coverage is presented by Brave
and we will be back with the start of
the second match on the other side of
this short break
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids that feels just like playing
but chess is a great way to learn
patience strategy and critical thinking
chess kids because of comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to Mastery there
are more than 50 000 chest muscles and a
whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies tactics openings
and end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
hey everyone GM Daniel nerdinski here we
asked the chess.com Community to show us
their best games from the cgc qualifiers
and we're here to highlight some of the
exciting chess that are awesome
community members cooked up in these
competitive cgc games now here we have
ckca who faces demoni 66 in a position
that looks pretty calm but watch how
quickly ckca goes after White's King
there's no Bishop on G2 the king is
exposed and boom goes to Dynamite he
starts by pushing his Pawn to H5 white
responds with an attacking move of his
own on the other side but black is
faster the pawn gets to H4 the queen
swings out to G4 and white thought that
he had everything covered with H3
pushing the queen away but no no no
Knight F4 check is a brilliant tactical
move using the pin against the Jeep on
forcing the king back eliminating the
pawn on H3 dropping the Knight back to
H4 and after H takes G3 White's King is
toast but ckca finishes it in style
there's many winning moves here but only
one sacrificial combination Rook H1
check and here demoni resigns because
after King takes H1 the queen drives in
to G2 with Checkmate what a lovely
attack from ckca and this has been GM
Daniel nerdinsky with a community
highlight from the chess.com Community
Global Championship qualifiers
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
World Championship in Reykjavik Iceland
it's been an exciting and amazing day of
action commentating alongside the one
and only International Master Lawrence
Trent I'm Jim Daniel nerdinski it's been
a pleasure bringing you the coverage
thus far and the new position for our
second match has been revealed there's
still a lot on the line you will not
want to miss this match I mean we don't
have all of the qualifiers secure just
yet Wesley so and Yanda palmnushi our
neck and neck will not Rebecca Abdul
sitarov continue his near perfect run
there's only one way to find out and the
players have just found out the position
which is now in front of us Lawrence
the players spending these 10 15 minutes
analyzing as quickly and efficiently as
they can What observations can we make
what moves can we suggest
what can we say about this unique
position
well I'm gonna have to retract what I
said before the break because this is
the first time I've had a real proper
chance look at it I think I think
supposed to do here with white is start
with either C4 or B4 uh and the reason
you do that is you activate the bishop
on A1 the king position is actually
reasonably vulnerable along that
diagonal and then when you play C4 you
activate the bishop on D1 you allow Rook
lifts as well uh the queen can come out
and so on so I don't know if you should
be starting actually with a move like E4
or F4 here because
when black replies B5 or C5 you actually
get hit on the long diagonals
that's my intuition about this position
I'm a hundred percent in agreement the
one thing I'll add is that there's
always this very interesting interplay
between who decides to play B4 and who
decides to play a little bit more
modestly with B3 I think feta Sev
um it likes to play more ambitiously
with B4 but Wesley I think has
demonstrated a more conservative
approach with let's say B6 so I think
that a lot of openings are actually
going to go B4 B6 I think we might see
one B3 as well and then maybe black will
go B5 so I'm really interested to see
what is going to be the interplay
between the B Pawns of course the
drawback of the move B3 is that it
doesn't give the queen quite as much
breathing room as you would get with
before but B4 comes with a significant
positional price tag I mean you're
weakening some of these light scores
here I think black actually might
consider a move like D5 although maybe
you're biting off more than you can chew
but Lawrence to make a long story short
I agree I think we're going to see a lot
of beep on pushes what do you call B4
what's the what's the proper name for
this in England
the orangutans yeah that's how I learned
it uh it might be it's also the Polish
the sokolski isn't it that's the other
sokolski is how the Russians call it I
I've always called it the sakolski and
it's named after Alexis sakolski I
actually have an original edition of his
book from the 50s on one before fun fact
back at home in San Francisco so
um yeah it's called the sakolski
uh I always really find it so
interesting when openings have different
names based on where they are the perk
by the way is the same way uh it's
called the ufinsev in uh in Russian so
we'll see but I think we're gonna see a
lot of sikulski
I also do believe we will
um I'm trying to think is there anything
else that really makes sense maybe a
ready is also sensible Knight F3 move
one and then maybe Knight G3 move two
you could even think about following up
with some H Pawn push as well
um yeah just to gain space H4 H5 makes a
ton of sense
ways to play this uh I'm I'm very
curious how they will go in this one
I think and I think we're going to see a
lot of short castles here like I think
the the easiest way is to move the other
night and then give a and then Castle
but you're right also h4h5
kind of like maybe even in some cases is
better than castling because your king
is already on the castle square and the
only point of castling short would be to
involve The Rook in the game but if you
if you're attacking the king side then
you most definitely still want the Rook
to be on the H file so
I'm very interested to see where the
sides will develop they're Knight D3 or
F3
and what are they going to prioritize
here that's always the question that you
want to answer and there's your random
positions you can't get all of your
pieces out immediately you're going to
have some problems so what is more
important to you here and I agree I
think opening up the bishop is the most
important priority
all right we will shortly
very very interesting
um let's talk a bit about one of the key
matchups the match-up of the tournament
for many people Carlson Nakamura
obviously
this rivalry does not need an
introduction
um
we can see
that they have equal points
um I think they also are fairly aware
that Abdul sorov is playing absolutely
blinding chess so there's an added
incentive to try to win this match do
you think Dania that compared to
classical chess ikaru
has got a better chance against Carlson
in 960. or do you think the Gap is
closer in classical chess
I think no I think he's got better
chances in any rapid time control
whether it's 960 or regular chess okay
what's interesting about the Rivalry is
that when they were playing extensively
classical you know there was a stretch
where Carlson was basically winning
every game but then during covet
something kind of Switched Hikaru flips
a switch uh they went neck and neck in
those online tournaments and ever since
then when they faced off in title
Tuesday you know when they faced off uh
previously in this tournament it seems
like Hikaru you know psychologically
he's reached a new level and it almost
appears to me that the ball uh from
again from a psychological standpoint is
is now in Magnus Carlson's court and
let's not forget that both of those
players have already qualified they have
knocked Vladimir fedesaf out of
contention but that doesn't mean that
they are not going to put every ounce of
energy on the line it's all about Pride
Magnus Carlson does not want to lose
both matches against the car Nakamura
that is the last thing he wants and of
course the car Nakamura well he plays
his very best every single game as we
see uh some obscure player adjusting his
pieces on camera there's feather save
and Bluebell but Lawrence what a treat
what a treat to watch another Carlson
Nakamura match
absolutely and I just want to say also
blue Bumper To Save is not just yes it's
not going to change much for the for the
overall tournament uh who goes through
or not but there's a lot of money to
fight for remember guys just got paid
jumps of five ten thousand so even that
mini-match there is you know relevant
and both Matthias and ferosev are going
to want it but in fact I'm just looking
now maybe blue balm is actually even if
he wins this match even if he wins his
match he might finish last but you can
see there eighth seventh and sixth place
uh ten thousand dollar difference so you
want a car that's a car that's a car
that's a car right there that's uh
that's uh something minus like a camera
like a 2014 Camry but still
it's a 20 well yeah I mean it's it's
it's a it's a Volkswagen it's whatever
you want
um and they're gonna fight for that but
I'm not exactly sure I think bluebound
might actually be last regardless of
what happens we'll see when all is said
and done
uh no sorry I've been upon gretison I'm
I'm just going completely there is a
fight for eighth and seventh gretison
and blue balm right
so yeah I think for the seven so are
safe
we'll double check that after the next
round but the games are off and hello
what is that I see out of the corner of
my eye
look at this a little bit of trolling
whoa
there you go for H5
LOLs I did mention it though I I I think
it's a serious tribe no H4 is this
you're a totally serious move I mean
it's one of White's best moves probably
in this position so they're not just
drawing if they go King H2 King H7
however
then we might have to revisit the topic
precisely
wow yes yes so is Carlson now going to
push his beep on or is he going to con
is he going to play Rook H3 or something
he's not going to play rookie Street
he's gonna he's gonna play E3
uh
before
it's kind of an odd move now it
surprises me now I expect B5 by Nakamura
controlling some of the light squares in
the center
I think I think B5 is I know Hikaru
likes the early confrontation between
the pawns so he maybe also will consider
C5
but you're absolutely right there's B5
and I
I don't know I think Carlson will have
to prove the worth
of this move because from a positional
standpoint Hikaru is very happy about
this
yeah absolutely and now I expect Knight
G3 by Magnus to prepare e556
yeah C3 and maybe 63.
but of course the drawback of that is
that the bishop is then temporarily
buried under the pile of rubble
that is true yeah I'm not madly in love
with what Magnus is doing here
uh not madly in love with it whatsoever
but Knight G3 C3
uh
uh C4 how about a Gambit Daniel C4 bc4
E4
I mean Queen's gamut accepted action
yeah
exactly I'm skeptical though hey I'm
usually all four gambits but oh that one
he's played it
dude you are on a roll I'm just letting
you call every move here but I the one
thing is he might not play E4
but Rook C4 is extremely old because it
runs into Knight D6 with Tempo and
central control and
not in the other night comes out to E6
and attacks the D4 but Magnus develop
some pieces here I mean Jesus I think he
is gonna go bc4 e44 I really do
I think that's his idea but
let's see if it works out
it's just I mean I mean we'll wait for
Hikaru to capture before we analyze but
Hikaru will take on C4 there's no way he
resists I mean the only other thing I
see is something like C5
but I don't see the need to get
Adventures then white will play D5 and
then E4
is especially Justified
because it blunts the bishop on A8
right
so very very interesting all right
I'm very curious I want to know what
Carlson wants to do I'm curious if on
the other boards they all went C4 on the
first move which and he does go C5
Daniel calling it moves here
we are but I mean all of this is
surprising me I mean I'm noticing these
moves
but I'm not expecting them
C5
I think he's gonna go I think he's gonna
go D5 here and on B Tech C4 try E4 and
play a benko Gambit declined
sort of thing
say that again after T5 you think he's
gonna go no c6p5 oh yeah there's a pin
down the C file as well which is
and ct4 simply Rose Queen C8 what a what
a strange position
but black is doing great I mean he's got
this added Central Pawn he can support
it with E5
what is what does white have to show for
all of the shenanigans
agreed B3 opening isn't black just
better after E5 yes or am I
misunderstanding this position entirely
which I probably am but
maybe E5 E3
ah maybe 5v3 he wants to reopen the
bishop
huh
so you know what a Hikaru move is Bishop
B6 I think is a hikaru-esque type of
move
Bishop B6 played
wow we're on a roll
on a real roll now Knight F3
now Knight F3 watch he's gonna play
Knight F3
come on Magnus
yeah he probably is but at 100 percent
Knight F3 and then 96 is that what we're
expecting
problem Knight f396 yeah I think so
there it is
still at 100 percent
that would be great if we just called
the whole game huh every single move
um I'm worried that he actually might
yeah 96 I think is a reasonable thing to
expect here
and then I think Carlson's gonna go
Bishop C2
mm-hmm
that would be my guess
yeah there's no other real there's no
really other uh move that exists here to
protect that pawn on D4
the problem maybe yeah there isn't but
there is
Queen B7 also exists
and then you might play E5
oh my God oh my God
we're just alternating that's crazy okay
my turn to predict Carlson's move all
right I'm gonna say Knight Knight G3
Knight G3 E5
Bishop C2
and then well my prediction is night
night
F6 okay
94. yeah okay Knight G3 I might have
another thing maybe E5 is a bit too
loose
uh if he plays statue three I'm gonna
lose my mind because number seven Moves
In
this has never been done before in
commentary history by the way no we're
already in record territory
okay the second move that I find to be
tempting here is E3
um to eliminate try to eliminate the
pawn on D4 but I I can only get one
prediction and I'm predicting Knight G3
yeah he might go Bishop C2 immediately
actually uh
Hikaru very comfortable Red Bull
we'll get that Red Bull yeah he's he's
like I'm chilling
yeah oh
[Music]
okay now I have the vested interest now
I'm I'm like holding my breath
now you feel disappointed when he
doesn't make your move
oh totally
totally it's because it's all about me
yeah
good play yeah Knight G3 or Bishop C2
I'm going for one of those ones I think
E3 is too loose
he has no choice he has to keep our
record going
come on Magnus don't be don't be a party
pooper now
get this night out bring it into a good
Square solid move natural you got this
but he he doesn't know what to do after
that that's the problem that's why he's
taking his time
yeah I mean my idea was Knight G3 Bishop
C2 and like Bishop E4
what about how about this Knight G3 how
do you like the move E6 there
okay
and Bishop C2
F5 to prevent anything Landing
on evil and and just totally restricting
me uh we got one wrong A4 way too and E5
Ayala
let's go as uh
no a44 I mean I guess E5 as a move and
he just snap played it and I'm starting
to feel yeah I'm starting to fear for
Magnus this is not the position you want
against your Karu whatsoever this can go
horribly wrong
is slow
I was thinking about it briefly I
thought maybe to start with B4 of course
the idea is obvious you want to go A4 A5
and knock the bishop out of B6 but
you're absolutely right after E5 you
don't even need the services of the
bishop on B6 it's done its job
and black has driven this wedge into the
center
how is Carlson going to deal with this
is he going to play E3
is he gonna play E3 now
I mean this might be his last chance to
play E3
hmm
this is weird yeah E3
E3 E3 is tough to play if you open up
the bishop towards that King
but you're right at least it pressurizes
some spots in Black's position
but no this is this is gone
no this is this is not a free Pawn don't
forget about that Bishop ah
can easily is so relaxed he is he's also
getting quite a decent lead on the clock
now I believe he's up
he does go E3
okay well done let's go
it's okay Hikaru will take because I
don't think any other move really makes
whoa actually that's not true right 96
actually makes a bunch of sense here
move to keep the tension he decides to
take Knight takes E3 will be played and
then I think Hikaru is gonna play
D6
I'm gonna call for
Knight G6 I know G6 sorry 96 is much
better but uh yeah you can't take on E5
just yet
and I'm thinking I'm very enticed by
this Knight F4 Knight takes two ideas in
the event that the bishop moves away
from D1 you know he's looking at that as
well
you know he's just oh yeah he's right on
that loves those kinds of ideas
and Knight G6 also enables black to
Castle should which is not you know
totally strictly necessary here but
still you want the king to be as safe as
possible
yeah so an interesting position he goes
F6 Okay so
they're disappointing us
F6 will Carlson continue with his plan
with B4 F6 side but f6b4 I guess his
main idea is to play with D5 and just
get the big sensor now that must be his
idea and then you can even go Queen
number seven Queen G6
but before it prevents it because if you
play D5 there's Knight 65.
oops
excuse me
and he's played before
might have underestimated this yes I
think he car underestimated the smoke
because F6 you have to agree is like
extremely committal in the positional
sense I mean it weakens all of these
light squares
there's a queen Pathway to G6 Knight to
F5 so Hikaru has to prove that F6 was
worth it
and he plays Knight E6 now
suspicious move F6 and I think car was
going to Castle
oh yeah yes
um
yes
a knight
what did he play Knight C7
uh
suddenly I don't like his position
anymore F6 this whole setup F6 I didn't
like you weaken all the squares around
the king
uh you can go Queen either sorry Queen
G6 Rook H6
exists excuse me
okay
so what do we play here as Magnus
by the way A5 is not ridiculous maybe it
is we drop B5 at the end
which is why it makes perfect sense I
think to move the Knight out of e3 where
do you move it well that's a question
but Knight F5
is I mean by the way attempting move
here yeah Knight F5 Knight D6 nearly
traps the black queen can you believe it
all right one square V8 but actually
it's just toes yes
he has played Knight F5 and I'm liking
it now for Magnus
Knight F5 yeah and an illustration of
how damaging the move F6 is if black cat
wait
why am I not am I
going crazy why can't buy Castle here
black can this is the unfortunately the
software bug we had yesterday
um we need to we need to do some work on
that unfortunately you are allowed to
that's okay
there we go okay there you go nicely
done
um not too difficult and now what you
need to do castles
97 King F7
now back to F5 rook h8 and we'll do the
dance 93 and we'll go back and well to
three three-fold reposition that way huh
it's even like this movie the Evo bar
doesn't like it but this illustrates oh
what is all of this a product of this is
all a product of this move F6 because
it's weakened these light squares so
let's see how Hikaru tries to address
that
Knight F5 is on the board
and Hikaru would definitely
underestimated the impact of these
weaknesses
yeah that wasn't too bad though castling
by hand
a good old-fashioned way
Yeah so basically we come to the
conclusion that F6 is bad in all
positions classical chess or otherwise
never play F6 bad move
of course take that with always comes
back
mm-hmm
a pinch of what we're going to say salt
I was good yeah I'd take it with a pinch
of salt pepper a pinch of pepper
um yeah uh
tough position now fikaru you can
imagine
uh
uh you know him going into the tank here
sure
I I could see him taking like 10 minutes
yeah this is not an easy position
actually very strange strange game
Black's movies and also white has got
various easy improving moves Rook H3
Rook G3 is your typical Rook lift here
that would be very nice you've got to be
careful of Knight f492 chip as excuse me
you cannot move the Knight on E6 it is
pinned so Rook H3 is
a legitimate idea
now so maybe Hikaru plays
D5
D5 it's loose Doha A5 exists at all
kinds so your idea is to unpin the
Knight but yeah A5 A5 is actually
another threat it drops the bishop
essentially
no this is flat out bad I mean 0.4 I
would not trust at all like there's just
so many threats I was thinking maybe
Queen E4
but then the bishop can drop back to C2
and again white will follow up with A5
ah maybe Queen E4 and queen G4 but that
we're entering like very speculative
territory there
yeah
now this is definitely
not good
for uh
for Hikaru and
okay Knight E8 is a panic
Bishop first of all exists oh my
goodness Bishop D5 exists your car
obviously saw that he wants Queen B but
that's a Magnus kind of idea Bishop D5
and queen E4
grabs control over the light squares
permanently so that's one option right
off the bat
97 check is
very tempting here
it is King F7
and then you have an OP you have a few
ideas right so I don't think you can
play Queen G6 check I don't think you
can go nuts so let's try Knight G6 after
that
you've got Rook H6 however
and I can't I wanted to play 95 but it's
so unnecessary to play like this because
Black's got defensive resources yeah
let's rewind that that's that's just not
what you want to of course you want to
look for the checks
likes 97 chicks somehow though what is
it oh Dania I've got a ridiculous idea
you ready for this
97 King F7 Knight C6 oops one moment I
apologize that was my bad
um let's go back to this game
oh
um
apologize for that we're looking at the
game on camera 97 check has been played
97 checking up some Knights C6 is that
ridiculous
oh and now I have it back up
and if DJ that's amazing if D6 C6 Knight
takes E5 check followed by Queen F5 or
Knight G5 I don't know which one but
probably Knight E5 or even but why not
start with Queen F5 or even Queen F5
straight away
simpler yeah because now if Queen E7
Knight G5
yeah all but U2 yeah
holy smokes and he I feel like Magnus is
going for it
it's an amazing spot by you 97 Knight C6
just stick the Knight right in Black's
Grill
a bit of sugar
yeah and also by the way 98 uh sorry I
beg your pun you're threatening maybe to
go A5 to distract this visual 1b6 the
Knight d8 oh my God unexpected check
winning the queen what are you allowing
yourself in this position this is just
this is just and by the way for example
let's say you did go
um
let's say you went Rook uh a rook it's
difficult to make a passing move but
I'll try it's even hard to like say a
random move yeah let's say Rook Hicks
you go A5
Bishop C7
right and now what do we think about
playing
uh no I can't quite make it we can go
Queen F5 we didn't have to go A5 A5 was
very I'll try this move on for size this
is definitely inaccurate but there's
just so many cool ideas like this after
Queen takes B5 there's the move Knight F
to D4 oh that's just too pretty I mean
it goes Knight she's six he went the
other way
yeah I didn't like that so much I felt
like the Knight got trapped there so he
must have an idea he's gonna sacrifice I
didn't like it at all
no no way 95 black just tucks his King
away on G8
he's gone Queen F5
what wait what is he doing what's going
on here there's Knight D6
so let's wait until the moves update
here Knight D6 by Hikaru instantly
and I think Carlson has blunted again
this is this is insane
he completely missed Magnus Knight G5
check and the King can just go to like
E8
and it's he forgot I think about the
mate thread on G2 sure remove itself
from F3 I think that made threat we were
joking about it but I think Carlson has
forgotten about it in a particular
variation
what the heck
yeah if Knight G5 then the queen from B7
and the bishop A8 combined to stare at
the G2 Pawn the position on the board is
what you see on the left this is what's
on the board it looks like white has
moves but he doesn't e8s
what an insane position
yes okay and King E8 but how do you save
a piece
your queen is hanging you have to move
it black takes on E5 and now he Karo is
on top here
this is I mean I mean Carlson will have
to step it up in the knockout
because these kinds of blunders are you
just don't see this from him no
you just don't see this from him with
this regularity
you know maybe once it once a rapid
tournament who wants a blitz tournament
not you know once every couple games
wowza now with this momentum shift
very very tough
to deal with
and you'll be looking what are the
king's on E8 I've got a queen on F5 a
knight on E5 of Bishop on B3
and I'm in trouble it's it's not every
day yeah
no no go ahead go ahead no no I was
gonna say it's not every day that you
have your pieces in stereotypically
fantastic attacking positions not even
material down and can be dead dead
Buster but I mean I haven't checked with
the computer 97 King F7 but Knight C6
looks entirely logical to me
just one it was the best move it was
okay yeah it was the best move it was
the only winning move but what's what's
puzzling to me is just that it seems
that Carlson's calculation has gone
completely out of the window it's just
he's you know he's going for the
tempting move
and you know he's missing stuff that he
normally sees in his sleep now I will
say that this game is very far from over
if he drops this queen back to D3 a very
important detail Lawrence is that the
Black Knight can jump into E4 with yet
another double attack the Knight will
still be hanging and the F2 Pawn will be
hanging as well so Carlson will have to
play this very accurately in order to
avoid losing in the next like five moves
yeah but if he does then the game
continues he's got obvious strategic
compensation in the form of his peace
placement but can he actually Safeguard
his King
crazy crazy crazy stuff
wow this is this is a lot to handle lots
of swallow
it really is a lot and Magnus Magnus
understandably in the tank here he's
probably asking himself what is going on
why why is this all going so wrong
um of course we are going to keep an eye
on the other games uh just by the looks
of things at the moment I do a center of
so is actually turned into a completely
Orthodox position
and that's probably very very level
uh gretison looks like he's got a nice
space Advantage also looks like it's
come from a classical and I told you
this didn't I Daniel yeah just before we
went I said this has got the makings of
a configuration where you will get more
Orthodox positions
is the only game which isn't and you
would expect that from anything photo
saved touches he's quite quite extreme
Orthodox is not in his dictionary
certainly isn't
so it's uh we're gonna stick with this
match for now this is by far the most
exciting position and we would like to
quickly shout out uh over 20k people
watching on Twitch and YouTube we want
to thank all the subscribers and twitch
primers who make live streams like this
possible so thank you for your support
we hope you're enjoying the show over
20k strong whether you're watching at
work at home
uh on the road
hope everybody's staying safe and
enjoying the Fisher random World
Championship
our chess.com coverage presented by
Brave we're watching Carlson Nakamura
and Magnus trying to wheel his way out
of yet another crisis
brought on by that Knight G6 blunder
and here comes 94 by Hikaru
yeah so 94
castle that's his idea
94 Castle Knights definitely
so let's analyze Knight E4 Castle yes
side note you can take the Knight on E5
right but then white gets two pawns and
some compensation
let's try Knight F4 that looks like a
juicy if you go Queen C4 targeting the
G8 Square
oh and if D5 there's a trip C6 yeah
although look at this line takes takes
check
you want to do it huh no wait wait wait
what's the best move
is it naichi 3 or is it like Rook G6
yes this looks very dangerous
yeah white has basically made it all of
a sudden this looks incredibly dangerous
easy tactic
and you know what that ambulance is
coming for the white king
excuse me excuse the uh the noises guys
but uh that's what happens when you live
in the middle of a big city
what's going on so 94 is on the board
okay excellent
this is the current position and I find
it hard to believe that Magnus will do
anything except Castle here and he will
basically say hey guess what my king is
relatively safe
black skin is no longer able to Castle
it's going to stay stuck in the center
and you know if Carlson can stabilize a
little bit he should be able to whip up
serious chances against Black's King
he's also down on the clock yet again
Hikaru has been blitzing these games out
yeah extraordinary stuff
I I've this is this has got all the
makings Danya of
you know
just a dramatic moment let's say a
dramatic
uh kind of uh
move or
theme it just feels like it's piling up
to explode but it's very exciting it's
it's like ravel's Bolero it's you know
the same Melody is just getting louder
and louder
and I'm a bit surprised yet again I keep
harping on this but it's just another
sign that I think magnus's confidence is
you know at a lower Point than it
normally is the time it's taking for him
Lawrence to play moves like Castle short
which to my totally untrained uh eyes
seem to be virtually forced like how
else are you going to propose to defend
the F2 Pawn you can't you have to
abandon any hopes of saving this knife
your priority is to save your king
maybe he's thinking about Knight C4
could this be what he's calculating
get some sort of fork going
very very important the old Knight takes
F2 at a minimum
oh it's getting okay
it's getting very very complicated
I just take your queen and I win the
night on B7
and white pieces are so discombobulated
that's very true yes
hmm
so maybe he's forgot how to Castle as um
that's not ideal jacket mate suggests
that would be yeah that would be quite
the hurdle to playing Fisher random
although when I was first learning I I
had no idea how castling works it took
me like months to actually realize it
and and fully Master the castling
castling rules
naturally yes
all right okay he's castled breaking
news alert
he has castled okay
now will yukaro make the Trent move and
play Knight F4 or will he grab the
Knight while he still can
big decision now is the ball
is tossed back into nakamura's court
what do you think
what do you think he's gonna do
I think he's gonna take the Knight
oh interesting and now you have to this
is the moment where you vote for Knight
F4
right
um I'm not quite keeping a cut an eye on
other games properly things look a
little calm
although nepo is going gung-ho
against uh gretas and the other games
look a little bit yeah
um
they look level at least
I Abdul satorav and he does take the
Knight but Abdus has a
stable end game pull against Wesley he's
got a risk-free position we definitely
don't have to go to that game that's a
pretty colorless game
the big one to me here is nepo because
nepo now probably has an advantage
and if he can win the first game against
gretison with black I mean he all but
guarantees himself a win in the match
but greterson has a very solid defensive
construction going so I want to stick to
this game I think everybody in the chat
probably agrees with us nobody will
blame us if we want to look at this
position but I'm keeping a corner of an
eye on the nepo game and should
something cataclysmic or interesting
happen we will update you on that game
as well so Rook to G6 by his Hikaru
aiming at the G2 Pawn boy does this look
terrifying for white boy does this look
scary
looks awful doesn't it I mean maybe what
are you supposed to do here
A5 how about A5 incredibly complicated
all of a sudden
um
A5
and Magnus does play A5 okay yeah and
you know what the crazy thing yeah
I mean it looks like mate almost but
it's just not right
it's not and the crazy thing is with
what's saving light is that you can't
move this Knight because the Rook on G6
Falls with check he brings this bishop
back and now Magnus can breathe a little
bit easier if he wants he can now move
his Rook out of F1
but will he do that and does that run
into some sort of Rook takes G2 move
which is begging to be played in a lot
of these positions
yeah this is terrifying
what about
A6 just to get rid of this gosh darn
battery
A6 and Bishop D5 Maybe
I'll be honest I'm looking at this
position and I'm I'm struggling with it
I'm I'm not getting a good feel for this
whatsoever
I like the idea of trying to eliminate
this
uh
uh this light squared Bishop this
battery which is just giving us so many
issues so I do like that yes
yeah I mean I just wanted to point out
that let's say white makes a neutral
move the reason
this fails it occurred to me is actually
because of Rook G2 but the point is that
you don't give the Discover check it's a
little misdirection you actually just
give the four kind of four you don't
really even need this battery
so that's out of the question as is
rookie one for the same reason
and I think white just needs to
I mean open up the floodgates a little
bit maybe stick a bishop on D5 try to
trade off some pieces
and ensure that this King
does not get caught in the crossfire
or caught under the Monstrous
combined Attack Of The Rook on G6 and
the battery on the long diagonal three
minutes now for Magnus
and again
experiencing problems with this clock
yeah not an easy positions plan what
move are they on actually that's also
something worth
finding out
only move 20. yeah he's got eight more
moves to make with no increment so those
five initial minutes
okay okay six
Bishop D5 I think
brilliant he should play it quickly I
think so yeah it's it's it's it's the
right move
and he does correct and he gets rid of
this this uggsome bishop on A8 and
that's a big step in the right direction
for the world champion
great sequence there
no it's you know so it's well it's
certainly tricky isn't it
in this position yeah
what do you do now do you take Go I mean
take how I think you have to thing you
have to take don't you
almost yeah I mean let me make a banal
statement the bishop is hanging as is
the knife yes so you have to take Queen
takes then the knights hang and then you
have to go like Knight F6
something like this yeah
I think Knight F6 is perfectly
reasonable and let's not lose sight of
the fact that black is still up a piece
but okay I play Bishop F6
yeah
well actually there's a rook G2 check
oh
what is happening that night on F3
holding the H2 square and here white is
probably winning goodness
my goalie what a position
this is nuts wow yeah you you got me
with King H1
Bravo Bishop D5 should be accompanied
with like two Advils like just analyze
this position
analyzing this position may cause
migraines actually H5 is hanging in a
bunch of lines isn't it now that I think
of it Bishop D5 Queen E5 Knight F6 I
taken take on H5 how did Hikaru not
anticipate this when he played H5 on
move one 23 years ago come on how
dare he not anticipate this
that is just so short-sighted of Hikaru
yes
okay all right should D5 on the board
move 23. correct your car with 10
minutes
so
what else
is he contemplating here Lawrence if not
Bishop takes D5 I I don't really
I mean he might just be trying to get
his bearings here right it might not
even be about oh I'm considering this
move you might be trying to figure out
what the heck is going on
precisely I think he's thinking uh I I
don't really understand
uh the position
per se so yeah I mean getting your
bearings here you don't know you know
it's it's very unpleasant when you don't
know whether you're
better or worse I I wonder if hikara
actually feels that that he he doesn't
he can't properly assess the position
wouldn't surprise me and I don't think
the players should even try to assess it
I don't think the players should even
try to assess it
I mean you just basically play it
doesn't really even change
whether or not you know the eval doesn't
even change the way that you play
because like White's going down a force
line
and potentially so is black unless ikaro
finds something
mind-boggling here
we might see your line let's see Yes
Trade on D5
right on D5
wait they did trade on D5 right I'm
having a hard time yeah taking on D5 and
25 now you have to save this Knight and
I I mean where else are you supposed to
put this guy
not clear at all right that's it on the
Lawrence Strat Square Knight F6 is on
the board and the bill Magnus snapped
that night off
I think you do right I think you just
snap it off
somehow I don't think he's gonna take I
feel like he's going to try to keep this
bishop and save it for a rainy day and
maybe give that check on A8 and follow
up with something
a little bit more open-ended maybe like
rookie one I don't know
two and a half minutes now
on the world champions clock
oh very very do you feel the tension
yeah I feel the heat I've just the air
is the same tension here
and imagine Carlson watching his clock
tick down and tick down
and the Jeopardy music starts to play
how long does Magnus have I can't see it
very well from a few minutes two minutes
two minutes on the die
and he's got seven moves to play that's
that that's that's tough that's rough
six six
no increment right it's not like when
you've got that two second increment and
you can fall down to 10 seconds if he's
got 10 seconds for three moves he might
literally not be able to carry out the
Moves In Time forget the substantive
quality of those moves which also has to
be high and he he gives that check on A8
he does
the king okay he's seven you would
suppose
for some reason my hand is you want to
go to the F7 but I agree it's it's not
for me yeah no I agree then Bishop C7
and 95 you're absolutely right King E7
is on the board
and now Magnus needs to find a slower
move
he'd be Queen B7 I feel like that's a
move in magnus's style trying to get the
Queens off the board yeah get yourself a
little faster
like love I'm calling Queen B7
absolutely love that but no he goes
through my original idea rookie one
still like that move to be honest with
the King where it is yeah yeah
when was the third move the top move is
indeed his move rookie one
incredible
the way he keeps his composure
really is okay
all right what to do now for black
that's the question uh
not easy at all huh
not easy at all if I may a very quick
update John is making progress in his
position he has a big Advantage he
probably should win Vladimir fettisafe
up a full piece against Bluebell
and Notre back continues to press the
end game but most likely that game will
end in a draw we'll update you should
there be a result but we are staying
firmly in this position with our seat
belts tightly fastened and with Hikaru
Nakamura contemplating his 26th move
seven and a half on the clock
yeah so he's still got the big time
Advantage so he can still have a go here
really struggling for moves so Danny I
won't deny it this position I feel a
little out of my depth I'm I'm
struggling to even see
okay he went energy forward did he just
play that
no I'm just showing with arrows I think
the reason he's hesitating about this
move I think most people probably in the
channel why not Knight G4 let's attack
this Pawn the bishop comes back to D4
this is the problem right the Knight is
pinned and you know what the problem is
here something Hikaru cannot forget
waitress takes on A7 there is a little
passer sitting on A6 two steps away from
promotion there is black cannot give
away the A7 Pawn for free
spot on
and he's played
Rook G4
to stop Bishop D4 well now Bishop D4
will be met with the Rook takes D4 and
he'll get three pieces for The Rook
what do you make of that one I like it
I like Rook G4 it's kind of out there
and we see a trait takes takes
maybe seven Queen no 95 okay
95 makes a bunch of sense
but he needs two more moves 27 six uh
Rook six H49 she's six let's not blunder
that shall we
well that's just I mean that is a
Perpetual I don't think that loses for
black
ah oh yeah you have Queen C3
does she have Queen C3 here
that's just now I just move wow you
found it
Magnus trying to hold this together King
F1
oh that might have been the Saving Grace
okay because Rook takes H4 Knight G6 is
a four okay Rook takes B4 then let's
keep on munching
I mean it looks very dangerous though
looks insanely dangerous
at a minimum Lawrence I have Knight G6
and like Knight h8 and a knight back to
G6
Magnus could breathe easy here he's got
one more move to make plenty of time to
do it I think Hikaru and I overlooked
Ting F1 completely
crazy outrageous
what a game outrageous you know if I had
to predict I think we're gonna see that
precisely that perpetual
I think Hikaru might have nothing better
than like Rook takes before
something to that effect and
the Magnus will start playing for a win
why is Rook tits before perpetual
well there's Knight G6 and 95.
you say you're saying I'll never go King
D6 there
I mean you are more than welcome to go
into six I ain't gonna stop you I mean
I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna do it
you're right oh my God
well apparently
I don't know if this is serious or not
no Rook take she too isn't they're just
Queen takes you too I guess that's a
troll
that must be a troll
but it almost works it if if you had to
take what the king it would work
unfortunately the queen guards the pawn
worth pointing out
huh wow again let's see it's been a bit
of a in a bit of a daze this game to be
honest it's sort of just this is what's
he gave up okay he's played yeah but
that's totally sad it makes perfect
sense actually to do what he did because
now he's gonna take the Knight back and
he has two pieces for a rook he has a
monster of a knight on G4 he's kind of
threatening Knight H2
and I still maintain
that only black can win this game
I think Queen takes before it was an
excellent practical decision by Nakamura
it eliminates a lot of the risk and it
keeps winning chances alive
well done Hikaru yeah I like it the more
I look at it the more I do like it so
now what though
now what do you actually update
yes better safe has won a very nice game
he's blue balm so that result is our
first official result
and nepo is on the cusp of winning his
game but yeah back to this one what does
white do well let's start by assessing
Queen takes A7 what happens here
as Magnus already back to four and a
half minutes
he's played it
H2 check
I think he's gonna go King
what he's gonna give up The Rook simply
okay in G1 I think he's gonna go King G1
and I think hikara will go Knight F3
check to crippled upon structure
this is really nice no he takes
immediately okay and he wants queen E55
Queen P5
also he might be winning here but with
that pawn on A6 I think it gives way
just enough counter play
or the draw I would guess
but I don't know how
huh
so let's take a look G3
Queen takes B5 Queen B7 B7 yeah
where do you go Queen if if you go Queen
A5 A7 Knight C7 I have Queen takes C7
um
yeah that's that's it is
this move
wow
the point being if you trade and go A7 I
stopped the pawn you can't go A7
immediately
no but this is practically speaking
incredibly hard to hold for white
I mean why does a full piece down yes
totally agree
so I guess you have this check and then
you have to go A7 and you have to
basically try to force that pawn through
Force black to give away the Knight
crazy
crazy what a crazy game this has been
just from start to finish
listen we normally we normally switch
around but it was so so worth
going along for the ride here
can we quickly switch the nepo game for
exactly 20 seconds
of course we can so because I it's a
huge game for the standings
and we need to figure out if in fact
Jana pomachi has converted his attack
this is the position
well that's uh goodbye that's that's
enough hope position I mean that's GG
right yeah yeah this is just oh my God
look at this line catastrophic Rook dh6
Queen E4 Queen G3
bang bang bang
mate wow
wow lovely mate well done it's over back
to Carlson back to Carlson this one's
over no question
folks relax not a single move has been
played in that game
you know
um not my first day commentating
I know how to manage this
Carlson's still thinking
and he's thinking about how to block
this check right
yeah yeah he does this he's going to go
Queen bison and Hikaru will play Queen
C6 of that I have no doubt
and he's done it
and my initial inclination was this
queen C6 move but it allows a nasty
check on B4 and then the pawn pushes up
to A7
and you know what the irritating thing
is for black like if black plays let's
say queen C6 Queen B4 check King F7 A7
it's actually hard to stop this Pawn
because anytime you do this yes you run
into this trick with Queen takes C7
so how do you arrange your queen at
night such that
I mean the knights only Square from
which it stops the pawn in C7 so how do
you circumvent this mechanism
is it no 94 maybe Queen C5 to threaten
Queen takes F2 and the point is if
you've got A7 queen of two queen G2 A7
then hangs
and if you go King G2 now I've got the
queen C6 check
oh yeah yeah so you run into that which
would be pretty nasty although it's it's
still not over there I can move the king
but okay A7 Queen takes F2 does black
have a win here
um
you have to do some sort of a zigzag
Maybe
okay I know you know use zigzag to C1
and you have to play Knight C7 I think
this is what you have to do and then you
get into this end game
and this is like a 50 50 position
but with Carlson's clock now below two
minutes I think he car's winning chances
will be Supreme
in this position Queen C5 played wow and
Magnus responsive King G1 he does not
want to give away any Pawns
he's still my beating heart
oh
what what is he going to do here okay
King G1 so there's a check on C1 which
is tempting right but the question what
does that check do white can even go up
to G2
Karo seems surprised is he on to
something here
is he onto something here
could be but I'm not sure what it is
what's the move I mean white
to play A7
hey
that is not in question
again if Knight C7 I still play A7 and
then Queen takes C7 is basically
Unstoppable
I don't see the win
no I don't know
I just I'm gonna predict a draw
yeah
I think that's a fair prediction
now the email bar is incredibly
inconclusive what does 1.8 mean in this
position what that tells me is that
there's some way to get a pawn up Queen
end game right yeah 1.8 tells me
squadish here basically
okay what it does it what it does tell
you though Laura is that there's no way
to like win the a pawn if there was a
way to win the a pawn it would be plus
six
but in the absence of that it tells me
that perhaps black can like win the F2
pawn and then give the Knight away for
A6 Queen C1 check played
King H2 and H2
now Queen C7 also possible oh yeah Queen
C7 exists actually you're right
Quincy says absolutely exists here
but Queen a
queen queen
uh-huh
what is what what what what kind of
Chess is this
look I want to play seven at all costs
no I understand that was more of a
rhetorical I got you I gotcha
so I think I know what's gonna happen
potentially what might happen Queen C7
Queen A8 Queen B6
now black wants to go Knight C7 and then
the opportunity train will have passed
so you have to go A7 at this point
and we've already been through this type
of position
here white potentially gets mated
and here at the very least black can
give the Knight away for the pawn and
have the end game that we've already
analyzed with the extra d-pawn
so this is one way that the course of
action could unfold
will Hikaru drop his Queen back to C7
here
what do you think of that no idea is the
honest answer I I'm this entire end game
I have just been looking at with kind of
uh drunk guys I I I'm not I'm failing to
grasp the subtle so he's the queen C6
the queen C7 the queen C5
yes sir
in the chat yasa sticks here but now why
does Queen be seven and if you go Knight
C7 again I have this Saving Grace on
before without which the pawn on A6
would have been lost
goodness mate is that the yes sir Sarah
one the one yes sir
in the chat
yeah so it's it's nice to see your name
uh
uh thanks for chiming in
foreign
s to be grabbed here though sir so
sorry mind Grabbers Anonymous is gonna
have to disband for the duration of this
game
Hikaru by the way as we're talking he
doesn't have forever he's got four
minutes
so
he's about to make a move you can tell
doing some last second calculations
double triple quadruple checking
oh
oh Yasser is firing back
I'm not I'm not watching chat but
whatever he said I'm sure it's gold
oh it is Queen C7
is a golden move by Hikaru and I think
we might see that lion
I think Carlson's going Queen A8
oh
no he gives a check
he gives a check
okay oh my God what's happening where
and
so full disclosure I thought Knight C5
permanently stops the pawn but
I guess I was missing something and
icaro drops his King back to E8 instead
allowing maybe the queen to come back to
B7
right
the hover hand there
was strong for both of them
oh my God the tension and janapovniki
has won his game
he has defeated some big big game
big big game
and Wesley might actually win his game
against abdusitorov
which is actually important we should we
should mention that that's actually a
relevant
uh a relevant result because
uh Wesley and nepo are very much
fighting for so Key Sport
and Napa was a point ahead right so if
both of them win their matches nepo
qualifies correct correct I I
I think so yes
I think so if never if NEPA wins he's
he's kind of guaranteed precisely
30 seconds for Magnus he still hasn't
made a decision after King yeah Queen B7
is the tempting move
20 seconds now
Tick-Tock goes the clock no he's
actually got more time than is reflected
on the clock I think he's got actually a
minute
and we've played a couple of moves here
King E8 is on the boat I again I I I
this is the exactly the sort of position
I'd lose with both colors
um
Queen D Queen D3 Queen B6 you gain hold
on a second 66.
where'd he just gave up the pause
I guess he couldn't have defended it
Queen takes G6 no but now white is
totally fine I think or maybe yeah
the past D Pawn is still a thing
so plus to rewind for a second after
King E8 he played Queen B5 hitting H5
dropped it back to D3 and Hikaru decided
that it's worth giving up
both of his kingside Pawns in order to
finally secure the A6 Pawn for himself
what an end game this is going to be F2
is also hanging with Jack by the way
let's not forget that either
yes
over how easy is that to miss I think
Carlson might have to go King G1 here
I think G1 might be the move
agreed I like King Juan
and he's done it
and finally this cancer on A6 is
eliminated but it's replaced by another
one on H4
Carlson is just a monster in these
positions he will not go gentle into
that good night
wow
do you have a read on do you think this
is just one of those weird sort of
equals positions or do you think black
is better or what what's your read on
this exact position here
um
I think this should be a draw if I had
to predict the likeliest result now
Hikaru of course is squarely playing for
a win because White's pawns are largely
immobile right anytime you play G4 you
give up the F4 score so Carlson
essentially has to keep checking black
and keep pushing the H Pawn that's maybe
the only Pawn that he can actually push
icaro has to find a way to set his deep
on in motion
and that's exactly what he's trying to
do with King E7 he's supporting the
Knight so that the d-pawn can move there
goes the train
wow
all right
H5 is coming
not the not not the not the slimmest
idea of what to do here
I know I've said that about five
different times but
it really has been tough to
to kind of
understand these positions they're not
at all intuitive to me
no I mean I
have absolutely no clue what the
evaluation should be here all I can say
is that Hikaru is playing without risk I
can't see black losing this game
the only way black loses this game is he
lets the pawn through
to H7
but that's not gonna happen
black also cannot win without promoting
the d-pawn that's literally the only way
in Carlson what a bold move as he pushes
the F1 up to F4
and Yasser thinks it will be a drug
so look at this D5 tempting Queen takes
D5 Knight F4 check Daniel not gonna
happen not in this universe but now you
can play D4
now you can play D4
yeah D4
who's better and why
Queen E4 though D4 gives up the E4
Square
and then there's a pin on the night and
Black's King doesn't have that many
options
true
very very true
okay Queen D5 played Queen F6
in G4 Carlson walking on hot coals here
every step is a step on 400 degree
squares
but there's no Forks yeah
okay what to do now for black how does
Hikaru make progress
how does black make progress
maybe yeah
maybe you have to just give a bunch of
checks or something I don't know
you can move the Knight
where do you go with the King and
White's gang will have a nice parking
spot 24-hour free parking on F3 where it
will a avoid forks and B be in close
proximity to the pawn and Hikaru drops
to 20 to 48 seconds on the clock
and he repositions his King to G7 both
sides maneuvering with their monarchs I
think we're gonna see a drop
even Queen E5 Lawrence I think might be
a drop
even the queen trade at this point
with white having three passers should
be a handy draw
Queen E5 I would play it here
I would play 25. just play two seconds
doesn't do it does not do it
still fine though King is blockading the
pawn that's true
and now don't play Queen E5 any longer
because Hikaru will capture on H5 the
Knight is anchored to the D4 Pawn
wow
32 seconds is that what I read here
this game is the best it's easy to
commentate these kinds of games this is
a treat
whoa whoa whoa there's a check on A3
wow
that drives the king out
no the king's name came by the Light
squares now he's gone backwards okay
because if he would have gone forwards
Lawrence Queen E3 Queen takes E5 would
have traded queens and then the pawn
would have promoted ah yes
that is but now the problem for Nakamura
is that he every move has to come with
check if he plays something like Knight
C5 Black's King is a Sitting Duck and
white has at least perpetual
and Nike what did he do
no I think it's just a draw 11 seconds I
think hikara has to Perpetual it yes
what a game five three
back
this is crazy and we crazy I haven't
seen the last of it just yet can Hikaru
trade with Queen G7
could that be a legitimate winning
attempt
Queen C8 setting up some kind of
discovery
and hikara will put it on D7 or no
on age seven check out five
both players building up time on their
clocks
and I think Carlson has found a
perpetual
yep
if Hikaru plays King f8 Lawrence then H6
and only black runs the risk of losing
wow
incredible
car was upset but man oh man what a
defensive effort by the world champion
wow what a game
and actually Carlson is the one flirting
with the idea of playing H6
yeah he might just play on because
that's what Magnus does Carl really
wants to play King f8 but he doesn't in
a wise decision and a draw and a
handshake and what a game
indeed wow
spoiled there
what a game of Chastity ups and downs of
fisherandam
how to even summarize it
well I think what a lot of people in in
the chat will not realize is that I
don't think it was ever that clearly
winning
right you know the evil bar even with
best play was showing maybe like 1.8 at
best
so Carlson's decision to go into that
end game where you've got that past Apon
incredible foresight
but all credit to Hikaru as well for
crazy resilient I mean he squeezed all
of the juice out of that position he did
everything he could
everything at her God's blue sky but at
the end of the day
a phenomenal resistance by the world
champion and a very fair result Lawrence
I think that's the only thing we can say
with certainty this was a fair result
completely agree uh
Fair great fight to Warriors what more
could you ask for really uh it was truly
uh a fantastic fantastic game
um
wow this isn't it we've still got one
more to go
we still have one more to go
and what's crazy is that Wesley defeated
Notre bag dealing him the first loss of
his tournament from a position that was
virtually unusable notorbeck
overpressing
blundering and losing just an incredible
result so both nepo and Wesley win
so Lawrence nepo
in Wesley needs nepo to lose the next
game if nepo draws or wins he qualifies
right
well wow it could happen I mean we know
nepo you know but he he is playing
gretison so
it's not a great spot
yes
that's a tough one that's that's gonna
be tough that is going to be tough
I mean yeah
wow I mean I'm speechless yeah I'm that
game has just taken the wind out of me
uh but at least we've got uh you know so
much tension left in in group a is
gretison gonna play the spoiler
is Wesley so gonna do the double on
Abdul saturov
uh
uh can you imagine
can can you just imagine that that
actually happens
will be sick to his stomach
you will totally be sick to his stomach
that would be unbelievable
and yes
I mean Carlson were a game two I love
the fact that these are mini matches
because I cannot wait to see what
happens with colors or first but before
we get on a short break refill our
coffees drink some water make sure our
seat belts are still fastened and the
contents didn't shift too much in Flight
we want to thank once again Brave uh for
presenting our chess.com coverage of the
FR World Championship Brave means
private browsing and more and so much
more by default Brave blocks ads and
trackers on every page and video you
visit even on YouTube no ads means up to
three times faster page loads faster
streaming and faster playback it means
35 longer battery life while saving on
mobile data and internet bandwidth for
Android iOS and desktop get the best
browser for gamers streamers and
creators which in 60 seconds right now
at brave.com chess well we had bravery
on display from everybody in the first
match game of today's second match there
is still Intrigue the final qualifying
spots have not been determined their
order has not been determined and we
have another Carlson Nakamura game
coming your way in just a couple of
minutes on the other side of the break
here at the Fisher random World
Championship we'll see you in just a
couple minutes
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess spoon with a duck quack
quack how to play duck chess the duck is
a brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck click on a
square to place the dog
oh he put the deck to prevent moves with
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
been permanently stop to London capture
the pawns Keen to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still mated player
wins ooh if only that was real chest I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
winning duck chess That's so exciting
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
I won
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you
[Music]
and we welcome you back ladies and
gentlemen to the 2022 Fisher random
World Championship are chess.com
coverage
is presented by Brave
and I'm here alongside International
Master Lawrence Trent oops Lawrence I
think is fixing
some audio issues and in the meantime we
just need to catch our breath because we
just saw an absolutely incredible round
of action as the camera pans out to The
Classy playing Hall at the Natura hotel
in Reykjavik Iceland a city with such a
storied chess past most famously hosting
Fisher spasky world championship match
in 1972 and now exactly 50 years later
another amazing world championship we've
got one more game to be played today
and in this game two main things are
going to be decided
we are going to see whether or not
whether Wesley or whether Janda
palmnushi makes the final qualifying
spot Into The Knockout if yanduponushi
makes at least a draw then he goes
through if Wesley wins and Yan loses
then I think Wesley goes through and we
will see who will win this epic match
between Nakamura and Carlson
Lawrence I assume you can hear me
I can hear you now loud and clear okay
I'm sorry to hear that I think you were
enjoying it
but uh I'll fasten to you as we look at
the the results here in the standings
this has been such a treat this has been
such a treat
it really has I mean what a fight these
two especially put on uh not leaving
anything uh on the side just every ounce
of their strength and creativity and
Imagination and fight and that's the
word and that's what I'm seeing a lot in
this tournament fight real fighting just
it feels like it it kind of in engenders
and and and
incentivizes more Fighting Chess you're
not seeing uh very quick draws at all in
any games they're fighting tooth and
nail to the last moment and we've got
the same position and look at that B4 I
mentioned B4 or C4 Dania uh Hikaru has
now gone for B4 which looks like a very
sensible move to me
yeah I mean this is I think what we kind
of started with I mean we were talking
about the sokolski and all that jazz uh
this is what it was in reference to I
think move one before is obvious and
you know we also pointed out that black
can play B6 or B5 Carlson with the
somewhat more conservative approach here
okay so far uh they're going down a more
logical path I think than in the
previous game
and never mind F4 okay
F4
wait wait Lawrence what if C5
well that was what was played wait what
is the car doing
like F4 is insanely random to me haven't
we learned already that moving the f
porn even in this situation is
too dangerous
this was a really bad move by Nakamura
he completely forgot about C5
oh my goodness he's already much worse
this is this is really bad I'm I'm kind
of surprised I have to say
I'm kind of surprised
I didn't expect that at all
oh this looks terrible for white after
Queen takes out four white needs to be
careful not to get checkmated basically
in the opening
right
yes this is this is not ideal to say the
least
huh
Queen takes F4 and if white plays CB I
mean this is like a millimeter away from
Chuck Mead why does have E3
but I mean look at Black's pieces the
bishop crisscrossing the king side
I mean
how is this yeah this is
stunning isn't it
well you could just tell the way
hikaru's sort of facing away from the
board I think he's just trying to figure
out what it is what the heck he just
missed there
just stunning
no it's definitely not prep it's
definitely not prep I mean the engine is
no it's throwing a minus one advantage
this is definitely some sort of wow it's
already Fusion already throwing minus
one wow
okay yeah yeah I think I think it might
have been some confusion from Hikaru
maybe he repaired F4 against a different
first move
but he is off
to a dubious start here doesn't mean
that the game is over I mean if there's
one thing we know for stern is that
Hikaru
is going to produce chances here one way
or the other by hooker by crook
okay Queen F5 Queen F5 okay
forced
yeah there we go Bishop takes those
Carlson
and maybe bishop F3 I mean how how bad
is this
I don't think it's probably not quite as
terrible as maybe even the computer is
suggesting
right
Bishop F3
yeah it doesn't look too
too out of line does it because once the
nights come out Night comes to G3 with
tempo as well
feels feels acceptable
I have a question though what about Rook
B okay
how do you defend
oh oh that's so pretty H5
I also like H5
I really like H5
I really your earlier idea lots of ideas
right you're trying to go h4h3 yes
White's in trouble on the king side
that's the bottom line here that's the
reason I'm concerned for hikaru's
position just
the General State of his development
here is disturbing
yeah and it's it's uh
it's
no no no this is this this is the Magnus
is certainly going to be very happy here
no question about it
I kind of surprised that
this actually happened
um
allowing C5 F4 is just and it's just so
out of
character it doesn't fit with the
position somehow I I wonder if it's
tiredness
I don't know but it's just not a move
that felt right because it was loose I
mean the pawn is just loose and you look
at the queen and I mean the starting
position you've already analyzed
you know or have a look at the potential
of the long diagonals right so it's very
bizarre
yeah very good D4 kind of douses the
position in gasoline but F4 lights the
flame I mean this just gives black Hook
Line and Sinker here with both of these
pawns now under pressure
so it's definitely something going wrong
there the good news for Hikaru is
obviously he's clinched the second
qualifying spot a loss is not the end of
the world but obviously from a
psychological standpoint from a pride
standpoint you know you want to end uh
the preliminary stage with a positive
result so his priority right now is to
figure out some way to get his Knights
out of the game to get castled and to
ensure the stability and safety of his
King my question what happens after
Knight G3 where is Carlson going to go
with his Queen
why is this so bad minus two
wow what
oh well I cheated a little bit but Queen
A5 is a super nasty move
now you're like you threatened me too
this is this really what's going to
bring by the way unfortunately for why
the answer is yes yes oh he's playing
93. oh no he played it off to take it
but Queen A5 anyway
same idea
and what's crazy is that if white plays
Bishop C3 Bishop takes E3 oh my God
have fun
yeah there's Queen A6 check and this is
over so
oh man that's very miserable okay so now
G3
uh uh I do like Queen A5
oh my God Knight F3
oh my God
Bishop takes D2
let's bring it on dude
Pana Harry and pun him one more time
Knight F1 H3
oh oh my God there's like so many cool
like ideas connected with the yoga Queen
zag nothing quite works but I think you
do probably you play H3
and just look at the weaknesses the
gaping holes on the king side for white
after G3 this almost results an
Unstoppable Checkmate I mean white needs
to basically bring his King up
and then the knights coming into G4 no
no no
this reminds me of a bit of bug
reminds me a bit of a bit of bug house
when you try and land that pawn on H3
you know just just pick up a poll and I
mean seeing Yasser in the chat broadcast
specialist how often you try and weaken
that King with with a with a Pawn on H3
um
but yeah outstanding stuff
just outside yeah I mean just
yawning weaknesses and in White's
position here and Carlson has to try to
keep his foot on the gas pedal
if white can get this other night out
and then get castled white still has
this asset the bishop on A1 aiming at G7
Black's Knights are not developed so
you know Carlson has to stay precise
here
certainly does
do you think he's going to go Queen A5
yes I do actually it feels like a Magnus
move because he's scanning the entire
board
and as we can see for a Super Chat yes
sir one not a fan of Knight G3
encourages H5 H4 push absolutely agree
yes I think I think it it massively
encourages uh
that kind of action
and queen G4 by Magnus he doesn't play
Queen A5
so my immediate reaction is that this
might not be the most precise move
and I have an interesting idea
I'm gonna take a page at a yasser's book
what about the move C4
and if H4 Queen F5 forces the queen
trade oh that's nice
might be more accurate
yes I feel like C4 might have been an
overlooked idea by Carlson right up go
to an idea
sorry Dania in that last position after
Queen ah sorry The Rook on a is hanging
I wanted to play Knight F6
actually that's maybe not so clear even
oh and he's can I put that up just I did
Castle okay fair enough yeah sorry put
up put up which line
no the line you just put after Queen E4
I wanted to try
um Knight F6 but it's probably a bit too
optimistic
no but again I don't like what Carlton
don't worry we we we can carry on here
yeah so C4 is yasa's um suggestion here
is it to be able to play C5
E6 yeah C4 looks good
C4 looks great and all of a sudden again
I think white is out of the woods
it's shocking to me still that Magnus
you know his greatest strength arguably
is just his ability to pounce and twist
the knife
the moment he senses you know a seam in
the position but it seems to me that in
this tournament he just
doesn't have that that Pizzazz you know
that verb that he usually plays with uh
when he's got the small advantage and
once again I think Hikaru will be in
pretty fine shape if he plays C4
instead
okay
are you waited for you to say that and
then yeah yeah that's that's normally
what happens the commentator's curse
um so h495 I guess is his idea
okay again c4l six
yeah but I like F6 by Carlson this is
one of those rare occasions where I do
like this move because you prevent 95
um and C4 has been applied
wow yes
balance and I like white center like
uh-huh
yes and there's a lot of stuff which is
you know important
yeah so
yes is a great player
yeah I mean this is a great human
actually
let's just go one above
the greatest H4 played now Queen E4 now
Queen E4
now Queen E4 will be played no question
this was the whole idea of C4 actually
well C5 of course
is part one but part two is that Queen
E4 comes at precisely the right moment
and it hits the Rook on A8 forcing the
queen trade Karo is in fantastic shape
here did Carlson miss this no I don't
think so
but black is just solidly worse now no
solidly worse I think so yes solidly was
like not even a question Lex pieces are
more passive on structure is inferior
and it's as though nothing ever happened
in the opening
wow wow yeah no this is this has been a
massive massive
uh Improvement for hikara Magnus won't
be feeling that great here
no no you know now this is unpleasant
for for black actually
this feels unpleasant yeah this is
amazing this is this is uh
basically a free hand for Nakamura I
would largely say they're playing for
two results uh too early to say that of
course because of how many pieces remain
on the board but
the car likes these types of positions I
mean who doesn't better end game
relatively no risk and White's going to
nurse the advantage um perhaps we should
go back to our bird's eye view
uh because
you know we have to be responsible
commentators and at least keep people
updated on the battle for the last
qualification spot that's going on so
while the smoke has cleared in the
Carlson game
shall we take a quick look at nepo and
Wesley's positions
absolutely let's let's go there
so nepo top left of your screen
let's start with the nepo game because
he's actually worse
he's actually worse against cratterson
wow can you imagine
oh my God imagine if Nepal loses Wesley
wins and in that case they tie in terms
of their match points and the
qualification spot will be decided by
the game point tie breaks I don't know
who's got more game points I think it
might be Wesley
could be Wesley will will leave that to
the to the mods
uh if that does happen of course
that bridge if we get there yes if we
get there because you know even though
gretison is slightly better is I'm not
thinking winning just yet
oh no no no yeah and I think what NEPA
might have overlooked is this move
Knight H4
in this position although
oh attention doesn't like it
the other move I thought about is Bishop
G5 to clamp down on the dark squares
but yeah I mean why is white worse here
like
okay so he castled I forgot about that
and that was again one of those whoa one
of those costumes in trouble yes
oh wow okay whoa so Castle's the the
engine likes does it okay
interesting so now like Bishop F6 Rook
G5 check is on tap as well in some
positions
this is concerning for Yan who is up
upon that's the one thing that's really
going for him and given an opportunity
he will expand in the center with D4 can
he stabilize the king side and can he
ensure that none of his pieces kind of
fall off the map here
that's the point isn't it
yes Touch and Go Touch and Go
is how I would describe that uh Wesley's
praying right now for to the greterson
Gods
absolutely yeah
because it's actually a really big swing
gretison wins this game Wesley wins
and he goes through
is like could it's a hundred and
protect 150 000
uh favor could potentially potentially
so that's such a big first prize that's
crazy it's such a big first surprise
it's it's just monstrous
yeah Napa will okay regretterson the way
he played if he manages to lose this one
I I think that's your best to date
I don't know if you planned it might
actually be top five of all time
it's up there it's up there during that
was great
thank you
saved the best for Less
should we have a look at the Wesley
Circle Game very quickly again I've just
said sort of just have a quick peek at
this position because for sure it's
interesting the bar is in White's favor
but
maybe it's just Bishop 181 is very good
basically and that there's some
attacking potential some F5 F5 ideas or
C4 yeah
well it doesn't feel like
but all Wesley needs us to draw
yes
game
exactly also we will need to come back
to the car again because I think he's
about to win
really
Hikaru is about to win
I think you're about to win we're seeing
him on camera
we need to go back to this game now
to draw some conclusions nepo was worse
but the position is unclear Wesley is
slightly better should be able to hold
at least a draw and if that is the case
then nepo basically needs to not lose
back we go to the Nakamura game
or maybe I overestimated it but can you
blame me for thinking this position is
like almost losing
I mean you're basically saying C6 Falls
and what is black doing
is that your argument
well I forgot that white is down upon
right now I apologize I thought that
white the material is equal and white is
about to win a pawn
the fact that Rook takes C6 only
establishes material equality change is
a great deal
so I amend my assessment to clear
Advantage for white
clear Advantage for white
yeah
what do you think am I overestimating
this
probably no
not at all
not at all look at that
wow okay yeah I would take white all day
here
I mean that's yeah it's clear that like
anybody who prefers prefers black hair
is is a lunacy but
the question for Magnus like can he find
a way to get around these nights I mean
there's like Rook H5
if he could trade one pair of knights if
he could swing the Knight back to E7
then that would at least relieve some of
the pressure
so from this perspective I thought maybe
King F7
or Bishop d8 in 97 he has played Bishop
d8
and that's a great move I think
he wants to play Rook tape c697 and
trait some pieces I guess
and get rid of this pesky Knight on F5
prove it
how bad is it
how about if you go Rook c697 I take it
I go Rook B1 and Rook B7
I mean oh
can we still Castle here
which move
can we still Castle
uh I think you can oh you can Castle
yeah
yeah that's going to be a critical move
um just to uh clarify things
so if Magnus
draws his game against Hikaru they tie
the match but Magnus takes a first seed
if nepo wins in the other group he's in
the semis
so it it doesn't matter actually we we
have an amendment sorry to cut you off
Lawrence we've clarified guaranteed
he's in and it's because of the last
game he's guaranteed I forgot to never
won the last game I apologize I thought
not what drew the last game he won the
last game so he's guaranteed himself at
least a point in this match and even if
they tie his head to head is higher so
his tie breaks are better that's it nepo
is officially in to The Knockout so the
four spots have been determined
so
the winner of this match fights nepos
and the loser plays Notre back who would
you rather play the world champion or
the world rapid Champion who's beating
everybody right now hmm well let's think
about that that's a great question
chicken or pasta yeah
exactly
not clear to me at all actually
not clear to me at all
in the meantime
in the meantime D4 I Mr Nakamura as he
spices up the situation in the center
tries to get his Bishop as active as
possible
what do you make about of that move he
takes D4 Bishop takes D4 on the board so
white accepts
uh another Pawn Island but the bishop is
now nicely centralized and White's minor
pieces are at an all-time peak in terms
of activity
I have to say I like it actually I think
it's uh
I think it's it's it's a it's a classic
a classic kind of move
so I do like it
I do like it I will say
yes you get that activity
yeah you get that activity and you know
Hikaru is so dangerous with activity and
all of that
um piece play now 97 is on the board now
Dania I know 1967 exists is he gonna
play Knight takes G7
is he gonna do it
I mean it's a movie it's a movie fall
off my chair it is definitely a move and
it needs to be investigated
King G7 Knight F6 great spot by you
so first primitive question
yes
no go why can't I just play Knight F6 in
King G8
well okay
King G7
and maybe now I can music so I've got
two yeah I go Rook af1 this is this and
then Rook F7 rookie seven is actually a
threat oh
okay I'm you're you're convincing me
yeah this is I'm convinced this is
definitely unpleasant okay but I'm not
convinced that black probably has a more
accurate move here
maybe King Jesus like King Jesus
now we need a stunner we we now need a
St but now we've got Knight E8 rookie
Rook F6
wow
and Black's gang suddenly kind of caught
in the crossfire King H7
Rook F7
Rook C5 no Rook F7 I go to H6 and I can
block with my knight on G6 he's done it
he's
he's been an experience it's not clear
right
we're about to get this I mean I think
Carlson is the joking G6
yeah yeah King G6 feels wholly natural
to me
holy natural
well yeah you have to get out of the
discovery yeah you you do
you do
seat belts if you unbuckled then we've
entered
we've entered some rough Skies
turbulence is beginning
Here We Go Again King G6 is indeed on
the board now we could have some sort of
a Perpetual there with like Rook F6 Rook
F7 very often these types of attacks in
the end game don't yield sufficient
attacking prospects for a mate but
frequently result in some sort of
repetition of moves where the king can't
escape Perpetual checks by The Rook
that's one General way the game could go
and given the email bar
I think the engine seems to believe that
that is the likeliest way that it will
go
it can go that but I'm just looking like
thank you I'm looking at these night
discoveries Daniel what about a move
like Knight D7 you hit the rook and
there's some 95 check stuff and Knight
takes C6 and is that even clear no
um far from Clear Rook H5 Knight S8
oh
King H6 the line continues Rook F7
well not quite
oh no sorry for all intestine purpose I
mean this is yeah but
you don't want to allow this
no I don't think so
and he's done it I've called it
you're unbelievable I'm just gonna shush
and I'm gonna let you call every move in
this game it's 97.
it's such a gorgeous move just
aesthetically I mean the geometry of the
way that the pieces are coordinated here
imagine not knowing the evaluation here
Magnus has to be terrified
in the situation he doesn't know that
this is he doesn't know that the eval is
all zeros
right
I wonder what he's going to do here
Rook well he's gonna move the Rook you
wanted to go Rook H5 right
I wanted to go Rook H5 and the position
that we were focused on after Rook F7 I
was going to make a crazy proposal
I was going to propose the move Knight
G8 and get mated no no sorry then here
there's Rook C6 through C6 yeah
Rook F5
okay seven King G5
96 King G6 and this is nauseating run
out
getting dizzy looking upstairs maybe
Rook F1
gorgeous gorgeous geometric
constructions here Rook F1 is a sensible
move but I would argue that it's a
little too slow
it feels like it seems like you're
relinquishing the grip on the position I
can go Knight F5 at least Bishop B6 in
some positions
a little bit more pizzazz
yeah I don't know I agree because 96
Knight f8 is always there oh yeah
yeah and King G4 gets mated so
um
so this is a critical position actually
can white find some way to spice things
up you can't go E4 because the Knight is
saying that's annoying
Knight is saying
you know
maybe just 96 and Rook takes 84. let's
not lose sight of the fact yes but white
yes just like in the previous game has
three passers on the king side plus an
attack
and two pawns for the piece at this
point
okay back we go to the live position
because they're making moves
Rogue G8
Rook G8 he doesn't play Rook H5 he goes
for the more Rook grounded move
and Yasser called it
to use the Rook as a blocker
in some lines of course you could give
it away for the bishop and get two
pieces for a rook
but this is incredibly scary so Knight
E5 check
King H7
then I can probably take C6
or Knight f8
yeah I mean 95 King H7 Knight C6
G6
excuse me sorry Rook takes okay little
part of the rush yep
okay but this I'm going to go
what am I gonna do yeah Rook F7 is
coming
a great situation where you just can't
look at the Evo bar
yes sir in chat saying take the pony
would love to just pick up that point oh
yeah
and that's Black's only passer so if
it's eliminated a lot easier
yes or applied for for a job the other
week
um
yeah on his CV they asked what
experience he he had professional Pawn
grabber
um didn't get the job so he's back in
chat with us
but uh
good luck next time yeah so if that CV
needs a bit more polishing they're not
just going to take you because you like
taking Pawns
yep you need some extracurricular
activities you can't can't just all be
you know on grabbing and Par grabbing
I feel like I'm I've like run a mile
it's like I I mean these out of breaths
we'll be honest these comment trees are
absolutely brutal as well
coming into our seventh hour uh we've
got of course people got to realize well
there's a whole production team here
we've got
all the configurations to set up
everything beforehand the run through
guys this is this is hard work to be
switching on and of course the other
point is we're not using an engine
so we're using this
sometimes Daniel's checking but we're
trying to assess these insane positions
and often blundering pieces do have
patience with us
and big shout out to dania
well big shout out to Lawrence you're
calling all of the moves you're calling
more moves as the commentary nears its
seventh hour I we we do turn the engine
on from time to time to confirm certain
conclusions but by and large you know we
try our best especially I think given
the spirit of Fisher random right the
whole point of fish are random the Zen
behind it is to avoid theories to avoid
preparations to make people think with
their own brains from move one so it
would be on becoming of the Spirit uh to
just over rely on the engine
agreed okay so Knight f8 or 95 I think
that's the big choice is there a third
candidate well maybe Rook C5 maybe you
just keep the tension and
you know add a little bit of gasoline to
the fire
or am I blundering something
no
I don't think you're blundering anything
just yet
hmm
Rook F4 also move I mean
I feel like it's hard for black to make
a move so maybe white shouldn't
you know
try to fix it if it ain't broke what
about Rook F4
what are you gonna do here
um I think that's a hit car that's a
hikara move right there
this is the sort of position which a I
need to be looking at it from the black
side and B I need to not be playing it
so I need both of those conditions
who defends such as well
Magnus Magnus
yeah let's name something maybe Magnus
is your guy
I don't know why I feel like your car is
going to make this move I just played
him so many times
no you please the Knight back T5
okay so he goes for the sort of
straightforward option
the king
can move up to H5 but we'll probably
drop back to H7 that was the point of
Rook G8
and it does
and SD card taking on C6 is that
is that what he settled for he does yep
I think he is yeah he's we're gonna go
down that line
Knight C6 36.
yes
and now Magnus needs now Magnus needs a
move
Rook G6 ah this is clever Rook F7 he
wants to go Knight G7 here perhaps or no
sorry 97 Rook takes G6
and then ikara wants to take on A7 and I
think we're gonna fizzle out into a draw
right okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is clever I think this is
starting to resemble you know some sort
of a bishop versus bishop and night
position
Carlson is going to have the push
chances but your car shouldn't have too
much trouble holding this
Rook F7
and
G8 Rook takes A7 is on the board
which Rook is Carlson going to take
not a question you ask yeah that's a
good question yeah
probably
you take a selfie A7
I know you well no he doesn't he takes
the C6 route
okay Rook
c66 apologize
and he's gonna slowly unravel on the
back rank
but Hikaru could push the a pawn if he
wants
of course that runs the risk of losing
the a pawn
but I I really don't think white is
risking here I mean three pawns for the
piece Bishop fully anchored by the epon
now this is a draw this is gonna be a
draw
unless I'm missing
or misreading the position entirely
yeah A4
I think I think white is the only one
with real chances here though Dania
right I mean you still play on if you're
if you're Hikaru
you know you're never in danger of
losing even if you blundered A4 it's
should be an easy draw you would think
yeah I mean you should be able to
exchange the H Pawn on demand if you
start dropping pawns then
you should be able to play g3 at the
right moment and worse comes to worse
Save The Rook versus Rook at night
but there's no reason the white should
give up
even a single one of his pawns much less
the A and E Pawns
okay but it's a try I don't think
Carlson is going to let the a pawn
through past day five
you probably should go King F7 at some
point
shouldn't he
just to unpin the bishop and maybe
prepare Bishop F6
yeah I think King F7 is
is just the move you you make
what else is
E6 yes yes yes sir proposing that one
mm-hmm
ah
oh wait I had a Brazen idea I'm I'm
looking at some tricks involving the
move A5 and try this line on for size
Knight D4 ed4 if you move your king up
and say okay A6 I'm just gonna stop the
pawn
A7 that's cute oh and this is still a
joke but this is still a draw because
black can basically take everything
yeah
still a draw H3 H3 is that a losing
attempt no I guess it's not no no I
think that's the easiest draw
oh you have this yes
excuse me so
um most of my moves and end games are
losing intense but Knight A6
comma unchant
I heard the Springer which is a night I
know Alpha is the bishop that's all I
know Knights on the rim
no it the literal translation is nights
on the edge bring
uh
uh shed something in shame like I
remember what it is
uh
embarrassment is it maybe I can't
remember
anyways the Knight on A6 leaves an
interesting impression
yeah
I can go to C5
I mean that night
is not stable on A6
I think it's probably going to last
longer than less trust but not by much
[Laughter]
very good Tanya very good
I'm surprised I was able to hold myself
back all commentary long you gotta save
the real you're not insulting me believe
me you you're not insulting me at all
I agree with you I've I've I've done
commentary gigs longer than Liz truss
was in power
foreign
Bishop C7 on the board I like this
attacking the H2 Square
actually this is a little awkward right
because you don't want to play H3 Hikaru
kind of
grimaced there he was he was a bit
annoyed because I think he's
understanding that Magnus is getting
reasonably well coordinated okay King F3
I think it's time to take the exit Ram
if you're a Hikaru I'm in Bishop H2 yeah
I think it's time to shake the exit ramp
and play rugby six
um
yeah
actually if you want to hear something
crazy after Rook B6 if I had to choose a
side I'd probably take White
am I after what sorry okay thanks for
saying that
yeah
because I want to go bishop d8 and I
want to win this Pawn
I don't think I'm crazy for saying that
of course obviously it's a dead draw
but if I anybody has to be careful it's
definitely black here
am I making any sense
no no you are making you're making tons
of sense
probably even Bishop C7 Etc but this is
exactly how you lose this is exactly how
you lose the Knight is tied down to the
a pawn
and the remaining two pawns can easily
tackle the king so
Carlson is probably contemplating Bishop
takes H2 and trying to find the sort of
most clinical way
to remove all doubt
about the result
when it looks like Wesley is going to
win another game by the way
or at the very least is going to hold a
draw from a position of strength
yeah he's doing very well
uh
and in the Greta Singh game yeah fair
play to gratison for a fantastic final
day after a really really tough
tournament he's doing extremely well
fair play to him
absolutely not easy just to come in
having a full-time job and
you know coming in playing all these Top
Guns quitting himself
as best as he could
beating Wesley with the black pieces
today and
uh formidable formidable effort by the
lower rated players in this tournament
to give the Top Guns a run for their
money and indeed guess what
we've got the trade of Rooks on the
board Bishop d8 incoming
foreign
and obviously this is going to be a draw
yeah I mean odds on at least right
holds on for a draw
not a hundred percent yet
but most likely yes
yeah we're looking at another camera
angle that's not on your screen but
Carlson
sort of staring in the distance Beth
Harmon Style
ikaro for once is looking at the actual
board oh never mind
so Bishop d8 he wants to go Bishop G3 ah
and his idea is King F3 Knight C5 A5
Bishop uh uh Bishop E1 this is his
genius construction
oh very nice and Hikaru should just take
on H4
your car should just take on H4
yeah I don't know why he doesn't take an
H4 of the previous move of course even
without Sans these two Pawns
Bishop against bishop and Knight is a
dead draw as this bishop against two
Bishops
Bishop F2 no
not Bishop E1
okay
at this point you can have this
repetition with King F3 and King G4 you
could take on H4
you could play Bishop B6 and Bishop d8
choose your poison choose your draw
what a match and even this game was
pretty entertaining I have to say
even this game was uh
had some had some punch
E4
is sakara's still trying is he still
trying some Shenanigans well he he
there's one last trick right Knight
takes E4 and then some kind of
you know
um King F3 or something
Knight E4 has been played
oh
King F3
yeah I mean it might still be a draw
weirdly but I'm not for example
oh no it's the wrong Rooks Pawn
I wanted to try something but it doesn't
Lawrence he did play Knight takes C4 did
Carlson see he took it
he did no wait wait wait wait wait wait
what is the draw oh I got it it's King
E8 but that's the only move that's
literally move
and wait a second now white has to be a
little a little careful here
okay
takes takes okay now just anything
anything you can probably even make it
to B6 if you wanted to eliminate the
pawn
yeah yeah okay and Hikaru had to double
check that that's why he's taking so
long on King F3
um
I got excited there for a second but
Carlson doesn't miss such things
Carlson doesn't miss me no I I would
have been very very surprised
to see Carlson miss that to be fair
okay King eight on the board
I think your car is going to take on h4n
yeah he's records will be signed on that
note
yeah I'm sure there's anything left to
play for here
all right let's wrap it up
and
there it is
trying fields
squeezing yeah every last drop out of
the position similar idea because now
you go King D7 right
I guess Kingdom Bishop F4
second
Bishop F4
F4
Bishop B1 do after Bishop A6 there
should be one
oh
King C oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait what
Bishop F4 where's the drama I'm sure
there is a draw but where is it he's
played it
holy smokes how is he doing this
wait what Carlson
and Hikaru casting a glance a Magnus
like uh
no it's still a draw of course but
oh my God he might have to give his
Knight away he missed that after Bishop
B1 white doesn't have to take on e4
white has the one a sixth
then you take okay this is still a draw
though
uh King C6 King takes he but is this a
true
yeah is this a draw
it has to be
I've had this end game before the pawn
is too far back okay because here's the
thing by the time by the time
also you can play H3
and get it into a corner Pawn but by the
time white dislodges the Bishop from E1
Black's King is going to be in the
Promised Land
so
just incredible the way Hikaru squeezes
out every last drop of blood of every
last drop of fight in every position
but it's a draw
well
Chase
Louise
I'm not sure what hikar is thinking
about here though
is there a move that's not King takes E4
yeah
six so I guess King F3 and King G4 is
the only way to proceed
yes right
yes of course and then Bishop G5 so
that's one two three four moves until
you and only then you take on H4 if I
were Magnus I would play H3
and I would use the technique yeah
I was looking at a funny line
so let's say white plays King F3
black plays H3
oh
wait maybe there's like G4
am I asking for trouble here or
something
uh
wow what
oh wait no no because this
it's never too late
yeah yeah
I'm taking a nap after this one that's
for sure I'm resetting my my vision this
is this is where the eyes start to glaze
over uh and okay so he played
Bishop E3 oh okay so he wants Bishop F2
but that's a draw
I think King B7 Bishop F2 takes takes
King C6
and G1
H3 G3
in T5 King H2 King E6 he takes H3
and you have five oh that's close this
is crazy it's closed so yeah I'm
calculating this and you could say oh
I'm going to get my opponent and set him
up with an h-bond this loses because
white pushes the pawn forward and then
wins H3
but I think that's like draws
by doing this
and then only now
do you play H3
right and then you go here and you're
just in here and you are just in time by
one tempo
but holy smokes you have to calculate
that there's also King G1
and try to go like this but here the
King goes at it the other way
and again barely but you hold it yeah H3
played actually
so Magnus going for our original idea
okay it's a draw
because now G4 I think the king is in
time
before
you can also Play Bishop H4 right
what about Bishop oh oh that's just a
fortress beautiful you got it yeah it's
your page for us
Bishop f2h2 right and it's yeah he's
done and he's played the car has to go
G5 and just take a draw yeah
don't go King E4
yeah there we go G5 Bishop takes G5 H2
he's played H2 first takes on G5
um
he'll make it and you'll make a knight
of the game
I knew he would under promote to a knife
you know Magnus so well that's just
unbelievable
that's ridiculous by the way
well hilarious sent to the game what a
match two of the most combative draws
that you will see
1-1 is the score
yes I'm with that of course as we said a
short while ago Magnus does take the top
of group
B uh-huh other games still in progress I
believe oh what a match Magnus will face
Janda palmnushy in a little rematch not
that the two have ever played before no
rivalry at all between them and Hikaru
Abdus and I'm looking forward to that
match with a special kind of Gusto
because of how many times they've played
in the rapid Chess Championship now I'm
just a tour of scored more than one
upset against Hikaru in the RCC so
Nakamura will have a chip on his
shoulder as they go into the match
wow what a series that is going to be
I can't wait but we'll have to wait
because there's a couple more games to
be decided
a couple more games still in progress in
particular Jana pomnia she has turned it
around against greterson and now the
Icelandic Grandmaster is the one
struggling to hold the draw
yeah he's had a few of these moments
uh to be honest uh has has
yeah and this position is is not holding
anytime soon uh you win you win H3 no
this this is this is not a hold
uh I don't think so so it looks as
though Jan is yeah yarn is gonna Jana's
gonna win I'm just a tour of
this looks
level-ish against Wesley yeah let's
let's let's switch to our bird's eye
view for a second just so we can
properly update everybody on
all the proceedings uh so basically we
have the nepo game on the top right
where yon looks like he's going to win
so's game on the top right is a draw I
think let's go to that game just to
verify that it is indeed going to be a
draw and if that's the case that'll be
notabeck's only mini match loss of the
preliminary how unbelievable is that
how unbelievable is that
yeah I think you'll be slightly
disappointed that he didn't get a clean
sheet but yeah we can't be too uh too
unhappy
yeah yeah
and we'll have bare Rooks on the board
no but Notre back well he's just yes
it's crazy how how he's playing right
now it's just yes the confidence the the
gusto
with which he he's playing every
tournament is is insane
there we go truly is
another one in the books um Wesley
doesn't get through but when's the last
match disappointing result for the
reigning Fisher random world champion
let's not forget that Lawrence A Rainy
World Champion is Wesley so and he
doesn't make it absolutely me too The
Knockouts shows you how close and
strength everybody is
indeed
and yeah uh putting the finishing
touches to yeah yeah so this game here
this is a classic
you use the pawns to Shield your king
from the check from the black Rook
so you'll go Rook a seven check and then
you'll slide that King into E6 and
um
no hope because also Rooks xa2 defends
the F2 Pawn which is very helpful and
that's the real problem that's the real
problem that F2 has defended when white
pushes F4 then obviously the king
defense so the rook and the King
alternate in terms of who gets to defend
both of white spawns loses
he seems a little bit Yeah upset I mean
that is just a rough way to end a 2-0
lost inepo with a good position at one
point at both games
doesn't
quite pull out a second victory but he
should hold his head up high it just
isn't easy to come in without much
practice and hold your own against these
monsters
and that leaves us one remaining game
yes yeah
blue bomb a completely random looking
position which
well
who knows
Vladimir won their first game so yes all
he needs is to hold a draw here and I
don't anticipate and he should have too
many difficulties although if anybody's
pushing it's probably black
just given the Practical difficulty of
keeping the knights well protected but
they are protecting each other
and black structure is horrible
so
I think that you should be able to hold
his own here
of course yeah this game
foreign
yeah this game doesn't decide anything
unfortunately both of these players are
out of contention but gotta say of
putting down a good performance honestly
showing that he can compete at the
highest level and I love seeing him in
super tournaments he's such a dangerous
opponent
always has been
and I still think that he's going to
make a serious bid
for a spot among the top 20 in the world
as he tries to stabilize on 2700.
absolutely I always enjoy him
uh watching him play he's
I use this word a lot for him creative
and he is
he he looks at chess in a slightly
different way I feel to other
Grandmasters of a similar level
he finds interesting ideas
um
so I really enjoy watching him play
would hate to play him over the board
absolutely hate I would not be able to
it's any of his moves yes have you
played him a few times Dania I've played
him a couple times I think I played him
twice in classical chess and were good
friends so I've played him probably in
hundreds of Blitz Games and training
games
and I would say that we probably have a
pretty similar style in some ways
but his positional understanding is
excellent too I think what a lot of
people forget when they look at a guy
like FedEx they think uh he's just
trying to get a chaotic position every
game maybe so
but just like t-ground petroshan was a
king of calculation and tactics you
cannot have this style and b2700 without
having a incredibly solid positional
underpinning that undergirds uh your
Tactical play and allows you to grease
the wheels of uh of of this kind of
creative style so he's got the whole
package
um and and he's had it for years
and it's unfortunate that we won't see
him in The Knockout but we will still
see
quite a few incredible incredible
matches as bluebound keeps the Rooks on
the board trying his best to level up
this final match
all right oh man
it's been uh it's been quite the day
Rook A2 on the board
I guess you go Rook B3 here just to
soften
there's no other move that really
yeah screams out
players then try and play Rook D7
didn't like what B7 as much but no
they're repeating they're repeating
moves I think
blue bomb is just going back and forth
ah okay they might be repeating
although it's weird because Matthias
does he win any money
if he ties this match is there actually
anything on the line money-wise
that's because if not I would totally
get it
no I don't think so we're being told
that he will be in last place sadly
regardless of this result
okay what is finna say of thinking about
just go okay five please no zuba is
literally repeating
not in Los
SES
oh
there are playoff matches anyway
interesting okay
well
consolation to be able to decide the
prizes okay so we'll see we'll see them
then in the next few days
uh they have decided not to repeat
Bishop B4 now on the board
yeah
um Pride
mm-hmm continues to poke and pride oh
this is great so we will see all of
these players again
and uh I'm a I'm a Believer in
consolation matches I think if you're
already there and you've qualified you
should get a chance to prove your worth
even if you didn't quote unquote make it
into the top bracket
Vladimir down to 30 seconds so this is
going to be while I think
but he shouldn't lose this
you just definitely should not lose this
no he should not lose this
yeah it's you know one has to be sad for
bluebaum a big fat donut
just but that's just part and parcel of
these types of tournaments you're just
not nobody's going to give you a pity a
Pity draw
I mean everybody's just going after you
right I've experienced that in
tournaments like the US championship and
they're not even close to the caliber of
this tournament oh I guess now they are
but
okay they're playing a bullet game
all right yeah down to Bullet five
second increment nice cd5 on the board
Bishop E5 looks like a the sort of move
you would play here just to
uh consolidate
yup I just don't get how Matthias is
going to make any progress even
hypothetically provided the white
doesn't blunder the knight in one move
there's just no breakthrough there's
nothing to attack D3 is protected by the
Knight so and the other night's
protected
they protects each other so
I I just don't see any realistic chances
for Matthias makes sense
okay Bishop
back Rook back to B7
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're just making
moves of course but
this should be a draw
King moves up to F3 there you can see on
camera
there we go E3 E3 and you can just go
back and forth between E3 and F3 if you
so desire
you can just sense the disappointment
matthias's face
it's just rough
you know to to have to suffer defeat
after defeat keep coming to the board
playing your best and he absolutely has
a lot of his games have been very
competitive
they've come down to the wire think his
match against the Carl good example
just missing that that umph you know
that last bit of energy that last bit of
tactical precision
that's what separates
i-2600s from the monsters
and he tries his last attempt F4
oh Rook C6 though Rook C6 here
but Bishop C5 Bishop C5 sorry but still
the king if King if King yeah black has
to be very careful
yeah man imagine if FedEx wins this F5
he goes F5 wait wait that's a bad move
now the pawn is a Sitting Duck
oh my God what was that five
years
now it should be five
yes nice let's stop by Bluebell Knight
D4 is a massive threat there's a mate
threat on E2
Knight F2 oh my God fedexv is panicking
and H5 here goes the pawn
oh my God is gonna tie the match here
with his first win of the tournament and
the very last game of the prelims
eight seconds it's still very difficult
is almost losing the night Knight C2 and
91.
not quite maybe just H4
97. but he goes up with the King no but
that forces blue bomb to repeat because
if you had won a G5 there would have
been a check on D5
ah okay
I think H4 is simple and very strong
because White's F2 Knight cannot move to
the maid on E2
doesn't do it
he's okay seven
King E6 I guess
mm-hmm
oh and if the Knight moves you have
Knight C2
and Rook takes F2 now King F5 is winning
whoa hi why'd you do that hey
this is probably still how was it good
what about Laura that was a terrible
move King F5 was game over
yes that was a horrible
this probably is still winning though
why did he take that Knight King F5 and
he had White's King in a mating net
weird question
very strange Not Gonna Save I think has
chances Knight H3 Knight F4
oh no there was Rook G3 okay
Bishop takes C7 move
was a shocker
I think it's a draw now
really
yeah I think yeah I guess it is right
yeah I guess Luma might lose one of his
spawns Rook C6 is the threat right
Rook A7 he'll play
yeah very good stuff by Vladimir 95
still trying okay six King E5 he'll play
oh my God Rook A5 and Rook takes D5 Rook
takes D5 no no no no no no no no no no
don't lose this if you're Matthias
oh my god do it
oh Matthias with another Heartbreaker he
just can't catch a break now you can go
Knight C3 and it's uh drummer I don't
know the pawn and game is the potting
game is lost
82 I guess he wants he wants a little
Fortress there
really still a dry thing
still a draw
eight seconds five seconds
back to D4
yes and now you can't go King E5 I have
to go King F7 yeah but now Knight F5 at
night is just easy
five or Knight F3 it doesn't matter
either way
yeah he goes back through here I like
this move
okay blue ball might have to go Knight
F4 and try to win with that extra Pawn
but at that point for the safe can even
give the Knight away for the fun we'll
be here for another hour if that happens
because they'll play Rook at night
versus Rook
oh God I hope that a safe can hold this
in a better way than that
now this is a job GA take H3
yeah just take H3 Knight F4
King H2S
1933 but okay this should not be winning
King up to E6 blue bombs only chance
might be either to get for the save to
walk into a fork
or to somehow get a mating that going
neither of those things are remotely
plausible given the location of White's
Rook
or maybe Vladimir will lose on time he's
already played he's already played two
strange I mean 96 King F4 he's already
making King effort King F3
I guess he has Rook okay but he's living
on the edge King F2 on the edge
literally
no now Rook a three okay
okay and King F2 you take the Knight on
D3 and block on H3 oh excuse me I beg
your pardon
Knight F2
I think you should try Knight F2 or
Knight E5
no 95 there's five I like to come to F3
he goes F5 so FedEx could take that pawn
and make an easy draw
but he wants to just draw this straight
up
why is this there's no nine and four in
1966 protects
oh my God why did he check him
oh my God and now 95 91 93. he got
himself
Knight takes F5 don't I think so five
it's still a drop it's still a draw keep
lost on time Knight if
you lost one second it's still a drop
oh my God
and a smile please sir all smiles oh my
Lance I think Knight F5 is still a draw
at the end
wow oh and how good the blue bum is able
to finally get a win
Vladimir in good spirits trust me if
there was a qualification spot on the
line there'd be a totally different
atmosphere
at this game ended the way that it did
wow
oh my God incredible stuff
what a day finish
what a day wow
oh my God so this is crazy okay all
right so first
all right wow what do you say in the
situation
well I don't know what you're saying the
situation I mean what you know you saw
finish over there with a with a right
smile on his face because what else are
you supposed to do except uh accept
smile in that situation we have been
spoiled today let's have a look at the
standings
after the preliminary
group stages
blasted through uh lost one at the end
but he
made sure of the top position long
before that game it is Jana publisher
who edges out reigning world champion
Wesley so Wesley so we gutted not to be
able to go through
and it is Jana ponushi fighting for a
classical World Championship is he going
to be a multi-world championship holder
by the end of next year we'll soon see
Wesley so as I said not able
to uh to go through and in group b
Magnus Carlsen just edging out Hikaru
Nakamura but both of those go through
Magnus in first position meaning it's a
repeat of the classical World
Championship Marcus Carlson and apology
in the second world second semi-final
and Abdul satorov against Nakamura that
has got the makings for an absolute
Blinder two very ambitious players
it it absolutely will be we want uh
no I was just going to go over the
format very quickly it's it's a it's a
it's a best of four
games so the first two and a half points
of course as always it's a unique
starting position uh elimination we're
in The Knockout phase now
and if we do get to Armageddon which is
of course a possibility there will be
bidding in order to determine who gets
the lower time control the winner
advances to the finals
who will then play for the championship
Fisher random World Chess Championship
wow I am blown out Dania that was
intense
that was uh amazing I mean and and the
greatest thing is that perhaps the best
part is still ahead the schedule very
important folks there is no Fisher
random chest tomorrow there will be
another type of tournament tomorrow
um which I'll remind you of in a moment
but tomorrow is a well-deserved rest day
then Saturday October 29th and Sunday
October 30th the weekend are the
playoffs semi-finals and the finals the
start time is exactly the same as today
8 A.M Pacific Time 11 A.M New York time
mark your calendars cancel your brunch
with friends don't sleep in turn it on
on the TV you will not want to miss
these two incredible matches and if
you're already experiencing withdrawal
and you're saying man I've got a free
day tomorrow I want to watch some chess
you're in luck because the women's
candidates tournament has already
started it started two days ago eight
players will compete for a seat across
from reigning Champion Zhu and June who
will challenge her in the 2023 Women's
World Championship who will come out on
topple you'll have to tune in to the
women's candidates tomorrow that's
October 28th here at thechess.com
Channel if you want more info type
exclam women's candidates in the chat
for more information it's an amazing
field two awesome matches being
contested in the women's candidates and
that will be coming your way tomorrow
with official random continuing on
Saturday
all right ladies and gentlemen before we
make our concluding thoughts a quick
shout out to Brave for sponsoring our
chess.com coverage of the Fisher random
World Championship switch over in 60
seconds at brave.com chess and on that
note Lawrence I'll pass it to you one
more time before I wrap up for your
final thoughts on a grueling but
absolutely epic day of Fisher random
action
yes absolutely uh it's been a pleasure
Dania as always to commentate with you
it's been up and down uh I have to say
some of the highlights that Carlson
Nakamura battle today was just so
intense
uh so much fight that's what I really
love about commentating on this
particular championship and we've been
spoiled also with the semi-final
pairings sure it would have been nice to
see an Underdog Story but
I think the majority of people want to
see uh the big boys really battle it out
and Abdul satorov the the one of the
shining stars in Chess World rapid
Champion Olympic champion now is he
going to do the unthinkable at the age
of 18 and become fish a random world
champion he's got a bit to go he's got
to get through Hikaru Nakamura first
before getting to the finals and what
about Carlson napomnushy a repeat of the
classical World Chess championships this
time who's going to Edge it out in the
Fisher random format we'll soon see epic
epic chess awaits don't forget to tune
in not tomorrow but the day after
and
we'll see over the weekend who becomes
fish at random World chess champion it's
gonna be amazing we will we will indeed
Lawrence thank you so much for lasting
through the commentary I mean this was
such a pleasure this was so much fun
couldn't imagine doing anything else
always a pleasure to commentate with you
thank you everybody in the chat on
Twitch and on YouTube for supporting
your favorite player lots of energy in
the chat over 25k at our Peak and we
hope to see those numbers and even
greater numbers over the weekend you'll
have no excuse no work Clean Slate
you'll want to watch you won't want to
miss it join us at 11AM and of course
thank you to our producer holla for
another Flawless broadcast these Fisher
random tournaments not easy to produce
uh and I thought today went incredibly
smoothly and now for everyone in our
amazing just.com team and everybody in
the chat damn Daniel nerdinsky and I am
Lauren strand getting you a fantastic
rest of your Thursday from the Fisher
random World Championships we will see
you
Saturday or the final matches goodbye
come on the Ravens
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]